[Musique]
mais bon on est bons messieurs bonsoir
nouveau recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle thinker view nous
sommes en direct on va vous demander de
vous présenter mais juste avant
olivier delamarche charles gave merci
d'être venus ça fait dix ans qu'on se
connaît qu'on fait des émissions sur les
questions économiques
pendant pratiquement une décennie vous
étiez les seuls qui annonçait que les
injections de l'idée à outrance pour un
oui pour un non un jour ou l'autre on
allait le payer en termes d'inflation en
termes de stabilité en terme de géo
stratégie géopolitique nm de guerre
olivier delamarche charles gave charles
gave est ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement s'il vous plaît
succinctement cela va être difficile
parce que j'ai fait tellement de choses
brillantes dans ma vie que je ne sais
pas par où commencer non mais maintenant
je suis fille d'officier je suis allé
dans la fpt dans l'économie et la
finance absolument par hasard j'ai
remarqué que les gens ne racontais que
les bêtises donc j'ai décidé de faire
leur cherche moi même et puis au bout
d'un certain temps il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui arrêtent est d'accord
pour me payer pour expliquer ce que je
pensais ce que j'ai trouvé absolument
miraculeux et de beussent jamais cessé
donc je suis parti pour londres 81 parce
qu'il faut les pas vivre dans un pays où
il y avait des ministres communistes et
puis en 2001 2002 sale angleterre
c'était plus pareil donc je suis parti
vivre une dizaine d'années en compte je
suis entré il ya 4 5 ans en partant du
principe que
peut-être mon pays allait avoir besoin
de moi quand je faisais des illusions
mais je continuerai olivier delamarche
ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement moi j'ai une carrière
beaucoup moins longue que charles maire
[Rires]
et
j'ai commencé en étant et entraîneurs
ensuite j'ai monté une société de
gestion que j'ai revendu ensuite je suis
parti on à genève un là j'ai monté un
family office
j'écris une lettre mensuelle et et je
fais deux ou trois choses comme ça donc
voila et tout va bien et je me demandais
tu vois si il ne fallait pas partir donc
c'est le type de questions je vais
tenter pas
on va on va parler c'est un peu plus
tard aujourd'hui on est très contents de
vous avoir parce qu' on va parler de la
situation alors premièrement comment on
en est arrivé à une inflation à deux
chiffres avec des politiques qui nagent
vous dire qu'il naviguait
à l'oeil pratiquement uni sans
perspective comme des poulets sans tête
à courir à gauche à droite charles
comment on en est arrivé là c'est quoi
c'est la guerre c'est pas la guerre
c'est les politiques monétaires c'est
l'inconstance et l'incohérence de nos
politiques qui c'est là c'est tellement
facile il faut revenir à une phrase de
jacques rueff bon jacques rueff c'était
un économiste qui a pas fait une bonne
chose mais enfin il a il a essayé y
réfléchissez bien il a une phrase qu'il
est toujours à d'oreilles de l'inflation
c'est de subventionner des dépenses qui
ne rapporte rien avec de l'argent qui
n'existe pas
passé à peu près tout ce qu'on fait
depuis
sept ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans donc si
vous subventionnez des choses qui n
apporte rien avec de l'argent qui
n'existe pas le poids de l'état dans
l'économie ne cesse de monter au fur et
à mesure que les poêles l'état ne cesse
de monter la part du secteur privé privé
ne cesse de baisser c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de nettoyage du système puisse
y a pas de création destructrice on peut
pas virer les types une fois katyn un
programme étatique est lancé ils durent
jusqu'à la fin des temps dans grosso
modo on a monté un système qui ressemble
de plus en plus à la bonne vieille union
soviétique et on est dans la période de
glace nassau ce moment où tout le monde
sait que ça va péter mais tout le monde
espère que ça va péter
quand ils seront plus la corée c'est
vrai ce que veut dire on est vraiment
absolument extraordinaire tout le monde
sait que ça va péter mais tout le monde
m'a tout le monde espère que pas tout de
suite record une minute monsieur le
bourreau c'est intéressant tout va bien
jusqu'ici tout va bien d'il ya au
troisième étage en arrivant du 12e casse
et
obliger la marche alors l'important
c'est pas la chute mais l'atterrissage
on va essayer de parler aujourd'hui des
répercussions que cela va avoir sur la
classe moyenne sur les gens normaux qui
bossent qui pose selon les règles du jeu
qui payent leurs impôts qui sont fiers
de payer leurs impôts
qu'est ce qui va se passer pour la
classe moyenne avec une inflation à deux
chiffres c'est quoi c'est un impôt
déguisé sur les familles qui travaillent
c'est une fuite en avant pour effacer
des dettes ou c'est simplement la seule
solution que nos politiques ont trouvé
pour maintenir le ronron quotidien et
attendre le déluge après leur mandat
c'est la seule solution pour moi pour
ben pour qu'ils gardent la leur tête sur
les sur les épaules c'est à dire que en
fait tu as tu as le choix entre deux
deux solutions la première solution
c'est de ces d'annoncer un défaut de
paiement annoncé un défaut de paiement
ça veut dire que tu dois arriver à la
télé tu t'appelles macron tu dois
arriver à la télé puis tu dois dire ben
voila je rembourse pas
essabah c'est une décision politique
donc évidemment on peut s'en vouloir
parce que tu as ruiné tout le monde n
est pas simplement
monsieur bernard arnault il n'y a pas
que lui qui détient de la dette tout le
monde détiendra donc donc en fait le
truc le plus simple finalement ces deux
sets pour suivre ce qu'ils ont commencé
il ya il ya 14 ans quoi et même avant
mais qui ont vraiment accéléré qui sont
jetés à corps perdu dans le temps la
bête et dans l'impression monétaire
depuis depuis 2008 est donc finalement
c'est ce qui a deux c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus pratique parce que tu t'es toujours
un responsable qui n'est pas toi c'est à
dire que et on le voit les on dit bas
mais c'est la guerre ah ouais d'accord
c'est la guerre sauf que les prix
avaient monté avant mais c'est la guerre
c'est la guerre c'est c'est le méchant
poutine c'est
c'est madame lagarde moi je suis pour
rien en tant que président c'est pas moi
qui fais un petit qui imprime les
leviers donc j'y suis pour rien c'est
c'est la politique des banques centrales
et puis et puis tu peux toujours dire tu
peux tu peux remettre le là la question
sur sur les gens eux mêmes mais c'est
vous qui avez dû perdu confiance dans la
monnaie moi si vous aviez pas perdu
confiance ce billet de 50 euros ils vous
paierai toujours la même chose donc en
fait c'est assez facile de se défausser
et c'est ça qui est en train d'arriver
c'est à dire qui se défausse en disant
bah voilà nous on n'y peut rien c'est la
guerre c'est c'est le fait que le
méchant poutine garde le blé est donc
qui va créer des famines et que ça mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec ça
les primes non c'est un catalyseur c'est
une c'est un accélérateur si tu veux
mais mais
si tu n'avais si tu n'avais absolument
pas une hier tu aurais eu ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui tu l'aurais tu
l'aurais eu dans six mois mais alors
enfin je veux dire ça n'aurait rien
changé
charles avec avec votre expérience
sont
d'accord a pris l'apéro
ça viendra après pourquoi vous rigolez
ok pour prendre au sérieux deux mairies
les répères les répercussions que ça va
avoir une politique inflationniste sur
les classes moyennes la santé pas
tellement les classes moyennes qui
m'inquiète elle m'inquiète bien sûr mais
la réalité est celle-ci si vous voulez
c'est que quand j'étais étudiant
quand vous n'avez pas très peu d'argent
comme
s'il était mon cas je payais mes études
du procès je faisais des tas de trucs
grosso modo votre budget est toujours
scindé en trois parties que vous en
dépenses et un tiers pour le loyer un
tiers pour la bouffe et attire pour se
balader ce show fait quoi l'énergie donc
vous avez un tiers un tiers un tiers et
il se trouve que ces trois loyers
énergie et bouffe sont la base de la
dépense des toutes petites gens ce
qu'ils sont tout à fait en bas de la
pyramide et chaque fois qu'il ya une
base impressionnistes c'est celle qui
montre le plus ces trois produits sont
soit qui montrent le plus donc ce nom il
faut bien se rendre compte c'est que
c'est les gars qui avait quitté remis
l'équipe éric et déploieront le 20 du
mois ça va être maintenant le 15 du mois
c'est à dire que vous vous êtes en train
de détruire
tous les gens qui
ils viseront plus d'argent pour mettre
dans la voiture pour aller voir leur
mère qui a la maladie d'alzheimer ou
d'anciens aller chercher les enfants à
l'école ça va poser un problème je
connais une jeune femme qui était dans
la région d'avignon bon ben c'est une
maison qui est à 50 km de l'endroit où
il bosse bon mais ça lui fait maintenant
à budget d'essence de 200 euros par mois
elle doit gagner à les 200 euros par
mois mais c'est à dire moi sur mon
scooter à paris vous savez pas ma vie
mais jamais été de cet euro de décence
il ya un an et demi et maintenant j'en
suis à 14 coups donc pour ceux pour
lequel le coût du transport il n'y a pas
de transport en commun est important
c'est une ponction ces crises ont même
plus d'argent pour aller au cinéma pour
aller pour se payer quelque chose qui
leur fait plaisir un match de rugby où
j'en sais rien donc c'est une attaque
violente contre les plus pauvres est un
système n'est juste que si c'est ce que
disait john roll qui était un économiste
enfin pas vraiment un économiste et
philosophe américain qui ont sévi en
vente qui est mort il ya une quinzaine
d'années il disait un système est juste
si le niveau de vie des plus défavorisés
montrent qu'en économie croît or ça fait
quinze vingt ans qu'on a un système où
les riches deviennent de plus en riches
on pourra expliquer pourquoi et les
pauvres deviennent de plus en plus
pauvres c'est complètement inacceptable
c'est à dire c'est un système qui a
perdu toute base démocratique on est
dans un système qui est monstrueux
aujourd'hui et moi ça me met dans des
états de rage complet parce que ben si
vous voulez je vois tous ces petites
gens dans la campagne qui souffrent
comme des maîtres quoi je sais pas
combien de suicides de paysans staff il
me semble qu'on est en train
d'essayer de rattacher les petites gens
à la terre à la glèbe c'est à dire on
avait réussi à la libérer
du servage on veut les ramener au
servage vous aurez plus le droit de
bouger et moi je trouve ça mais un sens
et
aussi les bulls ils vont forcément faire
quelque chose comme un chèque énergie
il vaut mieux ce que j'essaie de dire
c'est plus ils font plus plantes donc si
surtout comme disait la
l'armateur de louis xiv à saint malo
le 14 et comment je peux vous aider dans
votre concurrence contre les anglais il
avait appelé surtout si on ne fait rien
vous nous avez déjà assez aidé si
simplement ils pouvaient nous foute la
paix il était clair maintenant sur siph
donc ce n'était pas dans surcouf c'était
un corsaire c'était le patron des
armateurs au saint malo qui était en
concurrence directe avec les anglais
nantes le commerce et le roi disais
qu'est ce que peut faire vous aider il
avait dit surtout vous êtes gentils
scheer mais ne nous aidez pas donc si
simplement l'état pouvait cesser de nous
aider
s'il pouvait enlever tous les trucs
qu'il a mis pour nous aider par exemple
j'ai embauché une jeune personne ou la
semaine dernière à 2200 euros par mois
elle me coûte 50 milles à lagny à
l'année c'est à dire dans la place mais
où ou pas ce pognon voyage pourquoi
quelqu'un que j'ai embauché pourquoi il
ya plus qu il va à l'état et qu'elle son
salaire il faut que les cotisations sous
sol sociales sont mieux employés
d'accord charge c'est ça
je sais rien moi quand j'avais j'ai
travaillé à londres gta patron à l'eau
quand j'avais mon truc à londres bah si
vous voulez se distingua vous pouvez
travailler à l'endroit paris étape à
londres il avait un fonds de retraites
capitalisées ils avaient si
ça ne marchait très bien parce qu'il
pouvait prendre une mutuelle dans un
truc qui était acquis leur côté 10% de
leur salaire par par mois est pas et
c'était je donnais un à paris il touche
et 0,50 je donnais un à londres il
touche 0,90 et ils étaient mieux traités
donc la question est fier c'est la
raison essentielle mais où passe le
pognon pourquoi aujourd'hui la police ne
marche pas la justice ne marche pas
l'armée ne marche pas la dyspraxie ne
marche pas la santé ne marche pas
l'école ne marche pas et on n'a jamais
eu prévu des prélèvements sociaux aussi
incroyable donc mais qu'est ce qu'ils
font du fric c'est ça la vraie question
ils nous piquent du pognon pas dans tous
les sens et personne n'a la moindre idée
la première des choses qu'on doit
demander les français c'est un audit des
dépenses de l'état mais qu'est ce que
vous faites de notre truc
olivier
économiquement parlant quelles sont les
tendances à quoi s'attendre en ce moment
est-ce que ça va continuer l'inflation
est ce que on va sur un monde plus calme
plus en paix plus stable où est ce qu'on
va jusqu'à la bérézina monétaire
jusqu'au déni jusqu'à la négation ultime
voilà déjà tu as tu de deux personnes
qui nous ont gratifiés de
d'une bêtise énorme c'est de bruno le
maire et ses monsieur villeroy de galhau
celui des rois de galop et monsieur le
maire ensemble ne croit pas à la
récession datée dans le domaine de bus
religieuse à dire tu ne crois pas moi je
croyais que quand dieu mais mais mais là
tu ne crois pas la récession pourtant il
ya des chiffres et monsieur le maire les
a tendance à aller à les ignorer mais
aujourd'hui le premier trimestre est en
baisse situe le retraite il est encore
plus en baisse que ce qu'ils racontent
donc au départ il l'avait annoncé à 0
ensuite il l'a il a dit il a révisé à -0
2 en fait si tu retraite est pas loin
des -20 ans
pourquoi tout simplement parce que tu
t'aperçois que ça ne tient à peu près
que par le soi-disant investissements de
l'état la consommation de l'état et donc
et donc c'est cdc des chiffres qui sont
comptées deux fois qu'ils sont c'est
donc si tu retraite et était
probablement autour de - 1 sur le sur le
premier trimestre air - un ennemi aux
états unis sur le premier trimestre
tu es en négatif
royaume uni tu l'as tu es tombé sur les
deux derniers mois en négatif sur
l'allemagne mais c'est pas une récession
c'est pas une récession parce que
comptablement une récession c'est le mbr
qui décide alors il décide en général un
an plus tard donc content annonce que tu
as été en récession un an avant ce qui
est intéressant en soi
et
et ces deux trimestres consécutifs
c'est la définition de la récession moi
je considère que quand ça baisse et
quand ça baisse fortement et pourquoi ça
baisse fortement tout simplement parce
que les gens n'ont plus rien pour payer
1 puisque alors il ya quelque chose qui
est très frappant c'est que dans ce cas
dit charles charles dit qu'est-ce qui
quelles sont les dépenses contraintes
les dépenses contraintes c'est la bouffe
parce que faut bien manger et puis et
puis c'est il faut bien se loger tu
remarqueras que dans le calcul de
l'inflation
c'est ce qui est sous-évalué la bouffe
et le le le l'immobilier est donc on
quand tu quand on dit que on a 5 %
d'inflation on est au double voire au
triple donc évidemment que ça pèse
évidemment que des gens qui ont
manifesté pendant deux ans qui étaient
les gilet jaune parce qu' il pouvait pas
s'en tirer parce que à partir du 15 du
mois il n'avait plus rien sur leur
compte eh bien aujourd'hui c'est pas le
cas c'est le 5 et que ça peut pas durer
et que ça peut pas fonctionner et que
c'est parce c'est en plus on prend des
mesures qui sont des mesures absurdes
c'est à dire contrôle des prix on sait
qu économiquement c'est absurde on sait
que ccc mortels sauf qu'on fait
sauf que ces mêmes proposé dans les
programmes de certains est bien appuyé
dans les programmes de certains donc on
est on est dans quelque chose de 2,2
schizophrénique dans la gestion de
l'économie et ça depuis depuis des
années est évidemment ballack la réponse
à ta question c'est qu'on va se prendre
le mur mais d'une violence que les gens
n'imaginent pas charles est-ce que vous
pouvez nous aider à faire
phosphorer notre imagination le mur il
va être avec du crépi en béton armé est
ce qu'on arrive très vite dessus et
c'est à dire que vous allez rentrer dans
un système où d'abord il y aura les tout
petits c'est à dire que cette récession
qui va être important arrivera du bas
elle va d'abord ben si j'ose dire c'est
d'abord
les gens qui vont chez lidl qui vend
plus aller chez les hommes qui vont même
plus aller chez lidl des non plus de
quoi se payer puis ensuite ça montre aux
gens qui vont chez pas là chez auchan
puis ensuite sa montre et ça montre est
comme ça et ça se terminera par les
boutiques de luxe à paris donc ça va ça
va être une espèce de l'an étouffement
accompagné d'un désespoir profond parce
que les gens le font la plupart des gens
se disent enfin je travaille pourquoi je
réussis pas à vivre avec le le produit
de mon travail c'est quand même un truc
qui est très étonnant
mais regardez on vient de me dire il ya
des puissants gêné qu'il vient de dire
qu'il faut faire passer le smic à 14 ans
break 1 100 euros par mois ou
l'enseignant très bien est ce qu'il y a
un exemple dans l'histoire de l'économie
ou augmenter le salaire n'a pas
déclenché une récession le salaire de
base
dont il ya quand même quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est qu'on a
intellectuellement abandonné la méthode
expérimentale
c'est à dire qu'on est passé d'un monde
logique qui était celui qui ligotent
chouchi je pense donc je suis et
maintenant on est arrivé à un monde donc
j'aime donc j'ai raison
mais c'est pas que c'est pas la vraie
vie salle quand on est sorti du paradis
le seigneur m'a pas dit tu bouffes que
tombent les l'année prochaine ça ira
très bien il nous a dit tu travailleras
la sueur de ton front et si t'as pas de
blé tu vas crever de faim en grand et
donc dans quelque part il ya une en
étant rentrés dans une société magic
mois ce qui c'est moi qui me fera
beaucoup c'est dans le courant de ma vie
en l'espace de 40 50 ans on est passé
d'une société rationnelle où il y avait
quand même des gens comme raymond aron
qu'il comprenait quelque chose
à une société où dans le vent qui est
devenu complètement magique c'est à dire
que on l'a très bien vu au moment du
conflit avec la russie on a dit on va
plus on va plus importer aucune aucune
énergie de russie très bien sauf que ben
50 % de notre énergie venait de russie
et que bah si on a pas d'énergie band
pib va baisser de 5% simplement parce
que l'économie d'énergie transformer
certains de vos traces et donc je suis
là et je j'ai en face de moi des gens
qui gouvernent avec des bonnes
intentions
ils ne comprennent pas la réalité
donc on a en face de nous des gens qui
sont
je sais pas si c'est des rêveurs ou des
crapules ou les deux
ils comprennent pas le processus de
création de richesses qui n'a processus
un fils aimant compliqué donc pas oui et
je crois qu'une baisse de la qualité
intellectuelle de nos élites qui s'est
produite dans les 40 dernières années
qui est stupéfiante moi quand j'avais 25
ans
vivait à cette époque allemand à
revel jouvenel
sartre camus en a vu des gars rené
girard et 1 mais les gars vous pouviez
lire comprendre pour vous aider à
comprendre le monde aujourd'hui pour la
première fois en douze siècles
d'histoire de france il n'y a plus un
seul grand intellectuel français c'est
la première fois que l'espace
qu'est ce qui nous est arrivé pour qu'on
se soit crétiniser à cette allure là et
cette crétinisation elle se voit tous
les jours quand vous écoutez par l'aig
ils ont un défaut cabu l'air qui fait
je sais pas si c'est en moi si vous avez
de la chance donc il s'est passé un
phénomène dans nos élites c'est très
curieux
elles sont juste devenus
j'imaginais même chose s'est passé avant
la deuxième guerre mondiale on a vu un
effondrement aussi de nos élites
conscient mais il y avait quand même des
gars qui continuent à être serait
il ya peut-être des encore des très
grands intellectuels en france mais en
tout cas je le vois pas je les trouve
pas je sais pas où ils sont
et personne n'en parle ouais j'ai les
répercussions sur la classe moyenne
quand on voit le prix du blé exploser le
prix du mégawattheure a explosé quand
nous puissances nucléaires françaises on
accueille la moitié notre parc nucléaire
qui en état de fonctionner on est obligé
d'acheter la au dernier pic qui avait à
450 euros le mégawatt alors qu'on a
toujours eu l'habitude de le pays entre
30 et 50 euros la boîte donc le beh
l'électricité le maïs tout ça qui
augmente charles nous a expliqué que
c'étaient les plus vulnérables et les
plus précaires qui était qui allait se
faire tondre en premier deux ans juste
derrière eux
olivier qu'est-ce qui est selon toi nos
politiques dans un état d' aveuglement
c1 vaut mieux faire perdurer le ronron
quotidien parce que après nous le déluge
je ne veux pas laisser mon nom dans
l'histoire en étant le président qui a
assisté à l'effondrement de la france je
ne veux pas être responsable qu'est ce
que c'est ils ont encore un espoir de
sauver des choses où ça va être la lente
descente les chiens et chats sont des
crétins
ils ont faim quand tu
revois les déclarations bruno le maire
depuis le début du conflit
kisses bruno le maire le maire c'est un
gars qui passait là et il a eu de la
lumière et il est rentré au ministère de
l'économie et on l'a on l'a remis en
place parce que c'est on n'avait pas
assez de cinq ans pour voir
kylie qu'il était totalement idiot donc
ce type ce type
déclarations de bruno le maire au départ
du conflit je vais je vais écrasé
l'économie russe mais
peut pas être peut pas être plus bête
que ça les russes ils ont toutes les
matières premières encore les russes ils
font en fait
quand on sait comment ça fonctionne il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de
liquide qui circulent en russie sur
chaque contrat et donc en gros tu peux
tu peux multiplier par deux le pib donc
il est annoncé à 1610 doit tourner
autour de 3000 en réalité donc
trois mille milliards c'est plus que les
2400 milliards qu'ont fait péniblement
en france donc faut arrêter faut arrêter
de penser qu' on peut
sortir nos muscles face à quelqu'un qui
est deux fois plus gros que nous et qui
a toutes les matières premières on en a
aucune il y en a eu il a peut-être fait
pour deux pas de l'esbrouffe mais au
moins dire qu'il faisait quelque chose
de mes studios aliasé c'est d'abord
idiot tu le dis pas tu t'es et et tu
derrière tu n'essaie pas de coller des
sanctions qui sont totalement idiote qui
ne servent à rien qu'ils sont ridicules
sont idiotes pourquoi elles sont
ridicules c'est pas parce que tu sais
qu'il fallait au moins faire clic
chouine suisse abb pourquoi
mais les sanctions c'est un boomerang cl
nous frappent nos ça à partir du moment
où vous voulez et où
je vais essayer d'expliquer c'est assez
rapidement mais
depuis un siècle
l'énergie consommée dans le monde
80% d'origine fossile
rien n'a changé
ils ont dépensé plus de pognon pour des
miroirs magiques ou des moulins à vent
mais ça n'a rien changé c'est toujours
80 % il ya dix quinze ans les une grande
société pétrolière a l'air le second 6-2
l'homme
dépenser 600 milliards de dollars par an
en recherche pétrolière gazière et ses
dômes depuis on est tombé à 250 à 300
milliards elles ont complètement
d'arrêter leurs budgets de recherche
et s'il ya d'extraordinaire c'est que la
demande d'énergie continuent à monter
puisque l'inde continue à développer la
chine continue à développer donc on
arrive à peu près à 100 millions de
barils par jour aujourd'hui d'équivalent
pétrole
de demander
et la production n'est plus qu'à 98 donc
le prix du pétrole doit passer à 140 150
200 250 et c'est inévitable parce que
c'est très inélastique par rapport aux
prix ce truc-là l'énergie mission stade
des récessions trop lui même sur stade
des relations entre les deux il va lui
adresser gens mais c'est la seule façon
pour ramener l'offre et la demande en
face et la récession ben c'est pas ceux
qui peuvent se payer qui vont avoir les
récessions c'est ce qui préface le payer
donc en particulier l'allemagne qui
voyant une récession mais gigantesque en
allemagne les gens se rendent même pas
compte en plus c'est pour finalement ils
sont sur une balle dans le pied il avait
un avantage comparatif c'est qu'ils
savaient faire des belles bagnoles avec
moteur normal et maintenant et on leur a
dit qu'à partir des tringles 2035 il
faudrait que y ait que des voitures
électriques dans lequel ils ont aucun
avantage comparatif donc c'est un secret
que je dévoile ici de l'allemagne va
faire faillite dans les cinq ans qui
viennent nous au moins on a liquidé
toutes nos industries imbéciles parce
que c'est des allemands qui nous l'ont
pris mais ils ont pris dix ans pour une
industrie qui est condamné à mort si ce
n'est pas très malin donc grosso modo
vous avez une série de trucs qui sont en
train de se passer on n'a fait aucun
investissement dans l'ain dans l'énergie
on arrive dans une période d énergie
comme dans les années 70 et j'ai
travaillé là dessus depuis quelques
temps le cycle d'énergie ça peut
prétendre cinq ans pendant 35 ans vous
avez une énergie abondante et vous savez
ce qu'on appelle le marché aussi et puis
pendant va atteindre quelque chose comme
ça vous n'allez pas assez d'énergie il
faut faire des trous mais le trou coups
commencent à faire aujourd'hui où il
produira dans sept ans si vous avez de
la chance et la centrale nucléaire ce
sera dans dix ans encore si réussie edf
réussi à la faire donc vous avez une
pénurie gigantesque qui arrive donc s'il
va se passer c'est que de plus en plus
de sociétés vont être incapable de gêner
d'argent acquisitions à la cause de la
hausse perpétuelle du coût de l'énergie
qui ne va pas s'arrêter
et donc bah ce que ça veut dire
simplement c'est que comme notre note
énergétique ne va pas cesser de monter
en france en italie en particulier
eh bien on peut même pas dévaluer
puisque notre énergie autrefois on l'a
payé en euros mais avec les essais non
offrant d'abord mais ensuite on avait
signé les contrats avec la russie en
euros mais on les a annulé donc
maintenant l'énergie qu'on va devoir
acheter au qatar elle va être en dollars
donc autre fois c'est au moins un an
payés avec des trucs qu'on a pris mais
nous alors donné des petits bouts de
papier il était content là encore en
raison des mesures prises par monsieur
le maire c'est quand même brillant on va
la payer avec du vrai pognon qu'on peut
pas imprimer donc notre niveau de vie va
s'écrouler d'autant plus est ce que
j'essaie de dire c'est mais qui
a pris cette décision et pourquoi et
madame van der linden j'ai vu comment il
s'appelle la fonderie manderlay jan van
der leyen
elle a été virée du ministre et de la
ministre à la défense elle a des procès
aux fins tellement elle était nulle et
c'est cette femme qui a pris le pouvoir
avec une série de coups d'état qui a
décidé qu'on fermerait les rai
télévision russe les radios russes etc
et donc vous avez cette espèce de
groupe de pression européen qui à
l'occasion de cette crise entend bien
être ceux de prendre le pouvoir en
europe et gérer l'europe comme un seul
pays donc il ya derrière cette tentative
yar un coup d'état
pour enlever la dernière souveraineté
qui reste à la france et on a mis ce
qu'il reste avant tout la france c'est
sa souveraineté militaire est ce que va
chercher à faire maintenant mathieu
macron c'est à vendre l'armée française
ou ce qui en reste à l'europe c'est tout
ce qu'on a à vendre aujourd'hui
et c'est effrayant donc sur le seuil de
dire si vous les voyez avancé je ne
comprends pas pourquoi ils ont cette
espèce de désir de créer une
souveraineté européenne
connaissance totale d'aidés système
ils se disent que en fait il ya beaucoup
de gens qui pensent que le pétrole en
fait c'est un robinet donc tu coupe le
robinet tu tu remets le robinet et c'est
en fait c'est pas ça du tout c'est à
dire que ils ont pensé je pense que le
le savez juste pas bruno
c'est que il dit bah on va remplacer
demain le gaz russe par dudu du gaz
américain sauf que il a pas pensé qu' il
fallait construire 5 ou 6000 méthaniers
pour pour le faire qu'il fallait
apporter ça donc faire des allers
retours entre les états unis et la est
là et l'europe l'épicé sur l'équipe et
il fallait que le port soit équipé pour
détendre le gaz puis c'est du gaz
liquide qui arrivent il faut leur
transformé en gaz et et que ça se
faisait pas comme ça qu'il fallait des
milliards d'investissements qu'à un
méthanier ça se construit pas en une
semaine et que et que 5000 méthanier
encore en moins en une semaine donc tout
ça c'est 80 pour méthaniers avant qu'on
ait passé des commandes de l'europe est
là en plus ce que les gens ne savent pas
c'est que pour le pétrole c'est
exactement la même chose une raffinerie
s'est construit pour accepter telle et
telle qualité de pétrole un mix de telle
et telle qualité pétrole donc 40% harbi
saoudite 20%
pétrole de la mer du nord et c'est bon
et tu ne changes pas comme ça c'est à
dire que ton pétrole
de schiste eh bien tu peux rien d'en
faire dans la finale et donc il faut
changer la finale et ça ça se fait pas
non plus en trois jours donc tout ça
c'est délirant quand on entend l'europe
quand on entend bruno le maire qui vous
dire ben c'est pas un problème demain on
achète plus de gaz russe on achète plus
de pétrole russe et puis on va aller
servir non ça se fait pas comme ça faire
quelque chose mais pourquoi faire
quelque chose pourquoi faire quelque
chose fallait surtout pas aller emmerder
les russes avec en s'amusant à faire a
essayé de faire rentrer l'ukraine dans
l'otan c'est ça qu'il fallait pas faire
c'est qu'on n'est pas si les russes
comme vous voyez que même à oui d'accord
et qui les a poussés à envahir qui les a
poussés à harvey il dit il faut
condamner celui qui
fait la guerre mais il faut encore plus
condamner celui qui a vendu la guerre
inévitable
et je crois que ça c'est un élément
extrêmement important c'est que ça
faisait 14 15 ans que on essayait de
pousser la russie à la fois de bombes et
ça c'est un point dont on est fier c'est
que c'est pas le sujet puisqu'on
maintenant le problème ait fait ça sert
à rien de pleurer sur le lait qui a été
renversé mais encore une fois
il me semblait qu'il faut essayer
d'aller au fond des choses là
reste avait fait une typologie des
systèmes politiques aristocratie et
théocratie avait-il expliqué me
et 1
en fait il ya une vingtaine d'années il
ya un sociologue anglais qui a publié
une étude qui m'avait beaucoup amusé
j'avais publié un papier à l'époque
dessus il y à un nouveau système qui est
en train d'apparaître devant nos yeux
éblouis céline et stockera si
c'est à dire l'inepte au cra si d'après
sa définition qui remarque yann c'est un
système dans lequel les gens les moins
capables de gouverner
sont élus par les gens les moins
capables de gagner leur vie
tandis que les gens disent ils sont
productifs se voit voler le résultat de
leur production pour votre tir des gens
qui sont incapables de faire quoi que ce
soit
et se promener en inapte au cra si c'est
à dire que ça fait maintenant 25 ou 30
ans qu'on a des gens qui sont élus qui
sont
incompétents
inepte
et c'est un système auquel on n'avait
pas pensé c'est une forme de l'asema
logique l on n'avait pas pensé
et comment vous vous débarrasser du
netto cratie me regarder
dans le métier de journaliste quand
j'étais gamin il y avait quand des
journalistes et de sécréter dans les
années de gaulle et qui n'était pas
facile nava qui avait pas peur de dire
non
mais moi je suis stupéfait de voir à
quel point maintenant
vous avez un incident au stade de france
où il ya des gars qui se font casser la
gueule et on nous explique que c'est la
faute des engrais
les anglais eux mêmes disent mais pas du
tout nous on y est arrivé tranquille
dans sa fait casser la gueule et où
toute la presse française reprend c'est
la faute des anglais
toute la presse
il ya dû avoir valeur actualisée j'ai dû
avoir valeur actuelle mais sinon c'était
la faute des hooligans anglais mais même
qu'ils aient même accepté alors qu'il
savait tous que c'était faux
c'est quand même un truc extraordinaire
devra quel point il ya maintenant une
collusion total ce qui fait que j admets
bio bon ami journaliste qui disait que
deux sortes de journalistes en france
maintenant
via le journaliste honnête il ya suivi
un travail je n'ai jamais vue aux états
unis et en france une classe
journalistique tellement vendu au
pouvoir parce que quand j'étais gamin
aux etats unis les journaux les
télévisions les radios était détenu par
450 55 cents familles qui avaient des
des fiefs locaux et puis je vous assure
que sa vie allait entre les aujourd'hui
ces détenus par cinq grandes groupes
general electric on ne connaît tous
walt disney et bien aujourd'hui c'est la
même chose en france la presse est
détenu par quatre ou cinq grands groupes
et vous n'avez plus qu'à vous n'avez
plus de concurrence dans l'information
et il ya je suis persuadé qu'il va y
avoir un petit papier qui sort je sais
pas d'où le chaque bassin en disant
voilà ce que vous allez dire aux
nouvelles aujourd'hui parce que vous
prenez bfm tv vous prenez tf1 vous
proposez france de bouger il ya la même
déroulé des mêmes informations qui vous
sont donnés en même temps ça n'est pas
possible
normalement une conférence de rédaction
de vrai dire on va parler de ça plutôt
que de ça or ils parlent tous en même
temps de la même chose
10 vous reprochez à la presse de ne pas
faire son rôle éducatif concernant les
questions financier mais plus personne
n'est du coup on a décidé c'est ce que
dit le type brialy d'un café là
la prédominance
il avait appelé ça lol
le fabrique de crétins pour l'éducation
nationale
est un type qui a été professeur x est
tout à fait remarquable et bien lui il
dit que dans les années
90 il ya eu une grande réunion de tous
les gens en europe a décidé que ça
servait à rien des ducs et 80% des gens
qu'il fallait en faire des crétins et
c'est officiel ça a été dans les sept à
lisbonne ça a été dans le traité et
qu'il fallait se débrouiller pour avoir
une élite de 20% mais ça c'est officiel
c'est officiel mais vous c'est sans
doute bien vous avez carreaux gars vous
avez khadir brighelli
il a dit si tu le texte ici tout donc on
a décidé de faire de la france une
nation de crétins et on y est arrivé
et c'est là où j'en veux énormément à la
gauche c'est que la gauche c'était quand
même
le hussard noir de la république je
voulais c'était limite c'était par
l'éducation qu'on faisait qu'on trouvait
camus avec monsieur germain qui
découvrait camus alger ou avec c'était
ou avec tropicaux qui arrivait de
montboudif lors qu'il était exposé dans
mall sud aujourd'hui maintenant la
quasi-totalité des promotions de
l'ennahdha chez cette science po etc
viennent de 40 jardin d'enfants à paris
il n'y a plus
deux
de monter de la france profonde des
élites vous avez que des gars qui ont
été comme des poulets à l'engrais qui
sont tous bêtes à manger du foie mais
qui connaissent les codes pour être reçu
et je trouve ça
c'est une fragilisation de la france qui
est extraordinaire
puisqu'un système fragile c'est un
système qui ne résistent pas au choc or
ces gars là sont incapables de résister
à un choc qui sont jamais rien connu
donc il ya une espèce de
de prise de pouvoir par une classe qui
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
france thème ni le peuple ni la france
et même qu elle même c'est quand même
étonnant
je vais donner des noms j'aime bien la
diffamation pour diffamation à un garçon
comme gabriel attal qui est quand même
bien d'évoluer il sort de l'université
le gars il est engagé dans une mini sar
la santé comme conseiller l'a jamais
rien fait de sa vie quand il a encore du
lait qui lui sort d'une est un canton
presse dessus et le gars il est il est
conseillé conseiller de quoi compliquer
comment veux-tu conseiller taita jamais
on n'a jamais travaillé t'as jamais
d'affecter études tu es sortie de tes
études fait avec les du diable le
ministre a détecté un nouveau talent
d'accord si tu veux
et
maintenant ils se retrouvent ministre
ils se retrouvent munissent de quoi
vas-y tu sais pas les laits dans le lit
les pas de l'enseignement supérieur
c'est une blague c'est une vraie blague
faut arrêter faut arrêter tout de suite
c'est des gens qui n'ont jamais rien
fait de leur vie jamais l'âme les trois
quarts des politiques
peut-être plus que les trois-quarts
d'ailleurs sont des gens qui n'ont
jamais travaillé ils sont politiques
depuis quasiment leur naissance
un gars comme comme notre peut-être
futurs ministres mélenchon mélenchon
c'est un type qui depuis ses 16 ans
milite et l'a jamais rien fait 58 ans de
carrière ponot payés par nous je
rappelle tout de même bon non messieurs
l'intéressé 58 ans donc il doit avoir
bougé pas eu de morts 69 79 60 garneau
pourquoi il propose sa retraite c'est
imbécile puisque le travail est
tellement pénible pourquoi lui il veut
que les gens prennent leur retraite à 60
ans mais vont marquer que cette loi ne
s'applique jamais aux politiques
écoutent
pourquoi pourquoi ça doit être très
pénible de travailler quand même d'être
des temps dans la politique depuis 58
ans il faut le mettre à la retraite beau
garçon il doit est épuisé mais moi je
travaille parce qu'elle ait des gens qui
me paye et qu'ils sont contents de me
payer et parce que je leur parfois je
leur fait gagner de l'argent parfois
leur ont fait perdre sinon façon voit
pas parlé mais grosso modo je travaille
parce que je vais je prends l'avion à 6
heures du matin pour avec je regarde sur
les soulever par le hublot pour aller
trouver des clients à zurich où je sais
pas où donc ça fait des années que quand
je me lève à 6h du matin je vous assure
il n'y a pas beaucoup de fonctionnaires
à l'avion
donc encore une fois c'est pas marqué
sur leurs fronts mais aussi ses marques
et monsieur ici aussi ses marques et
lecteurs aux personnes en métal en fait
quand tu quand tu fais quand tu
entrepreneurs comme comme nous tu as une
sanction salaire si ça si tu fais donc
fait tu fait faillite un politique il ya
jamais de sanctions par définition parce
que si si jamais il est débarqué à un
moment ou un autre alors faut vraiment
qu'ils en aient fait une grosse une très
très grosse si jamais il est débarqué
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va le recycler
ya l'europe c'est la poubelle jaune delà
de la politique tu sais donc on va le
recycler on met on met un poste où le
gars il va finir sa carrière payer 350
mille balles par an
rien [__] mais mes et donc comment
veux tu que ces gens là qui n'ont jamais
aucune sanction tu mets un bruno le
maire dans une entreprise privée il
tient pas deux semaines gabriel at elle
me dit la communauté gabriela tel
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics c'est les comptes publics c'est
encore pire c'est pas compter le garçon
il vient à peine de sortir du cp enfin
je veux dire non non non non non
arrêtons
très spécial et qui est très spécifique
à la france et à l'afrique noire d'une
certaine façon mais c'est que
vous avez
en france un système vous avez des
grands corps de l'état vous passer des
concours
si vous êtes des grands corps de l'état
vous pouvez vous présenter de l'érection
si vous êtes élu votre carrière
continuera à avancer tranquillement
pendant que vous étiez lui vraiment et
puis si vous êtes battus vous retournez
dans votre grand corps à l'endroit où
vous auriez lui est si vous étiez resté
or dans toutes les grandes démocraties
historique la suisse l'allemagne la
france les etats-unis la grande-bretagne
le fonctionnaire est inéligible
c'est à dire qu'il peut se présenter ni
donne sa démission de la fonction
publique pour toujours et il ne revient
jamais donc là vous avez des gars c'est
pile je gagne face je gagne et donc
qu'on se retrouve à la tête de la france
avec une série de gars qui sont tous
fonctionnaires et la définition du
fonctionnaire c'est celui qui n'aime pas
prendre de risques parce que s'il dépend
des risques il fera autre chose et donc
ils suivent une politique pour ne pas
prendre de risque et grosso modo ce qui
s'est passé depuis
jusqu'à peu près si vous avez trois
étages dans un pays vous avez le peuple
vous avez la fonction publique qui fait
marcher l'état qui est une marche est
très compliqué et tout en haut vous avez
la fonction politique et le rôle de la
fonction poudre politique c'est que le
roi soit foudroyé coventry pétain est
foudroyé et c'est très bien c'est comme
ça que ça doit être la fonction
politique c'est le gars c'est le
paratonnerre c'est lui qui foudroyé s'il
fait une connerie bon ça me paraît très
bien mais depuis les années giscard la
fonction politique a disparu la fonction
administrative à bouffe la fonction
politique nous n'avons plus de fonctions
politiques en france il ya plus d'hommes
qui veulent faire de la politique vous
avez que des deux misé nuque de données
nuque il n'y a pas d' s il ya des deux
minutes qui sont là et qui sont et qui
sont qui se poussent les uns les autres
mais qui n'ont aucune capacité à prendre
des risques
et donc ce sont tous des gars qui
enterre les talents il enterre les
talents il en faire le talent il enterre
les talents et la france se demande de
quoi être grève mais elle crève de sa
fonction publique
une fonction publique quand elle c'est
de temps en temps ah bon système 210
ha mais celle là mais c'est pas là je
sais pas de sac par charles il parle de
la santé bougez pas elles marchent plus
la santé en france et je me fais la moue
qui oubliait mme soucy pas d'accord
quand j'étais enfant la fonction
publique et hospitalière ça marche i
mais parlez-en des médecins parlez-en
apéro mort par les a tous bien à part
les autres professeurs out etc
aujourd'hui la moitié de la fonction
hospitalière c'est des gens qui ne
voient jamais un docteur qui devrait
jamais malade ils sont là ils font des
papiers des papiers des papiers qu'on
envoie à paris qu'on envoie là et donc
vous allez aujourd'hui les médecins sont
comme des fous
ils se marrent fut la fonction
hospitalière nord fruits et moi j'ai eu
des gens la famille qui ont été malades
récemment il faut vous dire que le
personnel soignant est incroyable de
dévouement mais par contre il passe les
deux tiers de leur temps remplir des
papiers pour l'europe pour le
l'association des médicaments le truc
machin ils ne font plus leur métier pour
la file constat que nos élites
intellectuelles été un petit peu
mais c'est pas une élite
c'est pas une élite c'est des gens qui
ont décidé que celui qui avait la
capacité à passer des diplômes quand il
avait 20 ans parce qu'il n'avait pas de
besoins sexuels et qu'il n'est pas
besoin de faire du sport et qu' ils
étaient ils étaient ils étaient juste
seraghna voilà quand les highland si
vous avez lu le petit nicolas paganon
savez le 7 août la maîtresse bon on a
des arguments qui ont pris le pouvoir et
ils sont tous il nous
ya pas un gain de ségalar si vous étiez
dans une tranchée en 14 et qui vous
disent bon les gars on sort
bien voulu dit toi tu sembles moi je
reste un parce que vous n'avez pas un
gain de ses parrains de segalen les gens
ne vont les suivre un chef c'est
quelqu'un qui sort le 1er et qu'on suit
or macron il vous dit allez-y les gars
et puis il restera 45 vous avez été au
tour de l'elysée récemment c'est devenu
un truc mais on pose un blockhaus mais
c'est une histoire de fou une histoire
de fouilles au moins comme quand j'étais
qu'elle avait de gaulle je passais
l'ériger dans les pieds de voir les
puits à personne je sais qu'ils étaient
en danger de gaulle qui veut tuer macro
mais personne
est important oui c'est ma soeur de
gaulle si avec l'om c'est tout mais il
n'avait pas peur lui il avait pas peur
eux ils ont peur alors ça c'est très
important on va faire une petite aparté
la peur est ce que vous pensez pas qu'il
faut remercier ces gens là ils nous
offrent des vacances payées sur les
générations futures
là on a le calme social on a le chèque
énergie tout va bien il ya encore des
choses qui sont consommables dans les
supermarchés boya quelques produits qui
commence à manquer sur certaines denrées
qui coûte très cher mais est-ce qu'il
faut pas les remercier de nous accorder
un peu de temps et des vacances comment
on manquait de rien dans le goulag wahou
switch finalement manqué de rechercher
non non vous a été tranquille
qu'il faut pas faire si tu ne parles pas
quoi pourquoi tu fin
ccc l'oeil du cyclone n'a donc
qu'est-ce que oui en effet est un calme
apparent
d'un calme acheter comment permet de
trouver des solutions je me fais
l'avocat du jamais jamais ça c'est ce
qu'on a c'est ce qu'on a commencé à dire
dès 2008 où on a dit en fait c'est
provisoire tout ça on va arroser on va
empêcher les entreprises de faire
faillite on va distribuer du pognon par
tôt mais c'est pour gagner du temps
ouais d'accord pour gagner du temps mais
pour gagner du temps il faut il faut
faire quelque chose
mais il s'est rien passé enfin je ne
s'est rien passé il sait rien est ce
qu'on a reçu est ce qu'on a
est ce qu'on a fait quelque chose
vis-à-vis des banques 1 qui était qui
nous avait mis à ce moment là dans le le
le trou est
rien on n'a rien fait on n'a absolument
rien fait et et on a un prix mais on a
imprimé et là on est en train de faire
exactement la même chose on est en train
alors je te balance un petit chèque jeu
deux blocs tel et tel prix alors qu'on
sait très bien que on paye la différence
quand tu parlais d'edf tout à l'heure
mais quand
edf ont l' oblige c'est un scandale dont
le bcc ahurissant c'est ahurissant
l'obligent à acheter sur le marché de
londres vendre pas chez un ses
concurrents oui mais d'abord l'acheter à
300 balles et le rwanda 40 un truc et et
mais on nous dit mais non mais c'est
très bien on a bloqué les prix d'accord
qui va recapitaliser edf dans bond en
six mois c'est vous ben oui c'est
nouveau un petit peu quand même bien non
c'est tourner enfin je veux dire c
l'électricité augmenté à due concurrence
parce qu'on n'a pas payé jusqu'ici
évidemment souvenez vous un petit peu de
la drôle de guerre en 40 vous souvenez
landran 40 l'allemagne était en train de
mettre une raclée à la pologne la
tchéquie et puis nous on était là en
disant rester bien l'abri d'un ligne
maginot et ensuite tu es bien en juin 40
on a pris une branlée d'anthologie et ça
a été fait en cinq minutes donc encore
une fois
c'est le sait la comparaison historique
est intéressante c'est qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans la drôle de guerre on s'imagine
que tout va bien qu'il va rien nous
arriver mais dites vous bien que des
trucs comme disait de gaulle encore une
fois
il disait à quoi sert une place
imprenable à être prises
et donc l'euro par exemple c'est une
ligne maginot ça sert à rien ça foutu en
l'air l'économie française foutu bien on
va pas revenir dessus parce qu'il faut
pas tirer sur une ambulance mais quand
même bien l'euro est une imbécilité et
bien le jour où l'euro à sauter tous les
gens qui ont investi en fonction de
cette europe donc investi sur un fort
prix ils vont prendre des gamelles
d'anthologie il faut se positionner sur
quoi il faut passer en demies conseiller
de 800 à dépenser il faut par exemple
vous pouvez acheter deux choses dans les
marchés simplement de qui ça n'a pas
valeur de conseil est d'accord c'est la
passagère de conseils mais se dit
simplement une réalité économique vous
pouvez acheter une part de propriété
vous pouvez acheter un contrant vous
pouvez rien je sais d'authie rien notre
htc
l'un ou l'autre acheter un contrat par
exemple une obligation d'état français
que l'état français vous remboursera en
temps utile ça vaut zéro ça n'a aucun
intérêt si vous achetez quelque chose en
france prenait le risque de la propriété
déjà on va revenir sur autre chose
plus de droit de propriété en france
c'est quoi ça tutorat plus droit
propriété en france tu as vu que ce
qu'on a fait par exemple aux lakers
au russe russe on leur a piqué leur vie
là on leur a piqué l'or leur bateau mais
en dehors de foot en dehors de toute
législation on leur a confisqué une
entreprise qui s'appelait rt on l'a
arrêté donc il n'ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de droit qui te permet ça d'accord
il n'avait rien fait ces gens là je dois
dire non non mais t'es bon rien contre
la russie pour soi disant t'es pas en
guerre ces gens là leur seul tort c'est
d'être us demain ça sera les chinois
d'accord et demain ça sera le gac qui ne
plaît pas à monsieur macron
ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
finalement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui tu
n'as pas le droit de propriété n'existe
pas et donc qui va investir est ce que
tu crois qu'aujourd'hui un chinois va
investir en france banon il se dit toute
façon moi dès que mon gouvernement va
envahir taiwan
ont même confisqué mais bien on va me
confisquer la société pourquoi tu
investis avril a mis ses biens en france
dans l'espoir que de voir quelque chose
qui sont un petit peu aller à l'abri de
ce que va faire le grand chênois donc le
mans chinois dit vous voyez mettez pas
votre fric en france aux états unis au
canada parce que si jamais je me suis
fâché avec eux ils vous allez tout
perdre ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
quand même un truc qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est de me dire que ça nous
permettait de vivre au dessus de nos
moyens on vendait à ces pays de la
sécurité juridique donc il nous acheter
des actifs chez nous parce que chez eux
il n'y avait pas de sécurité juridique
mais appelle donc ça veut dire que nous
ça nous permettait d'avoir un déficit de
notre balance et on vendait des actifs à
trois ou quatre fois le prix parce que
c'était eux qui étaient contents de
l'acheter à partir du moment où ils vont
plus acheter on va être obligé d'avoir
une balance commerciale à léquilibre
peut-être ça c'est pas gagné eh ben
c'est pas ça veut dire que dalle niveau
de vie va baisser pour les importations
s'écroule coumet % à peu près où
commeinhes pensons à dc 10 20 30 40 bien
plus
30% je vais te dire à 30% c'est le sait
le prix d'une récession normale
sur les marchés en bon sens et le prix
d'une récession normale d'accord ce
n'était pas dans un grand soir marché
baissier vous avez le marché baissier
qui est fait
j'appelle le gentille ours brun qui fait
moins 20% et puis cela la peau si
rafraîchissant et puis vous avez vous
avez le vrai machin que j'appelle les
grêles et les grizzlies où les ursus
magnus les énormes baissier j'en ai
connu trois dans ma carrière et ça c'est
du 60 70 80 et donc il me semble que
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
qu'on commande pour qu'on ait un ursus
magnus en europe puisque ça fait 20 ans
qu'on m'a défaut prix il faut prix sur
la monnaie faux prix sur les taux
d'intérêts faux prix sur surtout donc
automatiquement quand vous avez des faux
prix le capitalisme ne peut pas marcher
bien se faire tondre
bien sûr on va se faire tendre mais
c'est en particulier tous les gens qui
ont des assurances vie qui vont
certainement savoir rien
rendu au caire dans lequel tu as des
obligataires ou autres bancaires ou
d'état donc après ta ta ta tout le reste
à l'assurance vie parce que ses produits
phares
aujourd'hui en france il y avait du sang
leader de danse oui mais mais tu vois
avait dans un livret a il ya quoi dans
un livre il ya des oublis
majoritairement française marchés
financiers vont coppola ils vont bien
ils vont pas bien le cac40 il a commis
au jour d'aujourd'hui vont ils vont très
bien les marchés phryne financier
puisque le le le bilan des banques
centrales quand tu regardes malgré leurs
annonces
malgré leur annonce en disant on va
arrêter d'imprimer ecsta mais tu
regardes le bilan des banques centrales
il n'a pas diminué il continue à monter
donc temps que le bilan des banques
centrales monte et bien tu auras des
marchés qui se tiendront qui monteront
qui se tiendront mais tu ne tu n'auras
tu n'as pas d' alerte tu auras et c'est
pour ça que moi je je je je maintiens
mes mes prévisions là dessus je dis dans
trois mois les banques centrales parce
que à ce moment là les marchés
commenceront probablement à jouer le
fait qu on est en récession il seront
aperçus qu on est en récession à ce
moment là ils commenceront à baisser
qu'est ce que feront les banques parce
qu'elles ont fait depuis 2008 c'est à
dire que elles remettront du papier et
puis peu importe c'est l'inflation
repasse mais si le prix du pétrole passe
de 100 à 200 pendant lequel fond ça on
est cuit oui mais elles le font quand
même le fond c'est à dire que en fait en
fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui
tu n'as pas de rétropédalage possible
c'est à dire on sait la cavalerie tu ne
peux pas aujourd'hui que quiconque
central qu'est ce qui va se passer là
aujourd'hui on est quand même monté on
est à on est à 3,25 sur les sur les taux
italiens bons sur le 10 ans italien on
doit être autour de 3 à 3,25 3,25 sur le
taux italien mais c'est insupportable
quand à quant à 180% de dette ça n'est
pas possible et ça n'est pas possible
sur la grèce n'est pas possible sur
portugal ça n'est pas possible sur la
france tu ne peux pas te permettre avec
l'endettement qu'on a et ce qui va venir
c'est à dire il faut rouler les les
positions
il ya des gens comprennent pas c'est bon
vous avez l'eau taux de croissance du
pib de créés par le secteur privé allait
produit intérieur brut mais enfin en
principe ceux qui payent des impôts
c'est pas l'état c'est le secteur privé
donc il ya ça fait à peu près 15 ans que
l'italie n'a pas eu personne d'autres
payent les impôts qu'il ya du secteur
privé parce que l'état n'a pas ce que
des impôts sur les messieurs
les actionnaires c'est nous qui les
payons du cirque avec l'os qu'on leur
paye comme un truc pour le secteur privé
c'est moi qui paye des impôts des
fonctionnaires c'est pas des êtres
fonctionne à free la pêche chez moi donc
c'est un truc il faut savoir aussi bon
mais le secteur privé en italie n'a
jamais cru maintenant en nominal de plus
de 2 % par an depuis 20 ans les taux
d'intérêt sont à trois et demi
donc ça s'appelle une trappe à dette
c'est à dire que la richesse concret
monde 2 % par an et la dépense et la
dépense de monte de 3 et 10% par an
c'est une différence d'exposants ciel on
saute ça n'est pas possible autrement
soto s'appauvrit oui mais à ce moment là
on s'appauvrit encore les italiens ils
peuvent payer peut-être gagner parce
qu'une grosse partie de leurs dettes et
détruit par les italiens eux mêmes
tandis que nous 50 à 60 % des détenus
par le qatar par la hollande etc donc si
nous ont pris les taux d'intérêt à 3 et
10% ça veut dire que de niveau de vie
bas ça va baisser d'un pour cent par an
a signé pour cent par an mais
mécaniquement c'est pas possible
autrement donc ça veut dire que tous les
directions calotte de travailler il rend
possédant la city à londres où partiront
dans un en asie etc donc on va on va se
retrouver avec que les retraités en
france
et toute la culture de la génération de
mai 68 va se retrouver avec une
une retraite très triste
le pire c'est
charles vient de faire de la
démonstration
sur un pays est endetté à 100% quand tu
es endetté à 160 et que tu as des taux à
trois et demi ça fait 5 qu'il faut
sortir tous les ans
c'est pas possible alors qu'est ce que
ça veut dire qu'est-ce qu'elle étendra
dire on est en train de dire quelque
chose de très intéressant c'est que
cette construction imbécile de l'euro
elle a commencé par faire sauter toute
l'économie du sud 1 ça a ruiné
l'économie du sud deuxièmement ça fait
sauter toutes nos banques 'l'indice des
banques c'était 4 50 points à 10 des
banques était à 4 500 aller en 2007 il
est à 90 aujourd'hui pendant que les
banques suédoises sont à 700 ils sont
par allons donc c'est à dire que ben si
vous avez prêté à des gens qui peut pas
me rembourser les fonds propres de la
banque fonde si la banque s'apprête à
galles mais la dernière étape de la
ruine de l'europe c'est que maintenant
ce que cherche à faire les européens
c'est un robinet les rentiers c'est à
dire tous ceux qui prennent leur
retraite pendant de 1945 à 2012 la
bundesbank payer entre 4 et 5%
d'intérêts réels sur les sur les
obligations allemandes ces débats
difficiles avant des erreurs des
retraites capitalisées
ça marchait très bien maintenant les
taux d'intérêt allemands sont à moins 6
c'est à dire qu'en disant toute la
classe la retraite en allemagne va être
lessivées c'est ce qui s'est passé dans
les années 30 quand il ya une
hyperinflation
donc leur aura détruit d'abord
l'économie du sud ensuite le notre
système bancaire et enfin tous nos
systèmes de retraite et sig en samarie
au système de traite que ces crétins
arrêteront peut-être de voter macron
parce qu'ils ont tous voté macro comme
un seul homme alors pour propres aller
concret quand on le sait kong mais
moi aussi j'étais retrait chez mort de
peur
pourquoi pas si c'est parce que j'ai
plus de bas ma retraite je vais pas la
toucher ou un clic aux pays bas ce sera
comme le général de l'armée rouge qui
touchait sa retraite tous les mois et
lui permettre d'acheter une baguette
quoi en 1998 parce que leurs hommes
avaient baissé de 98 pour ça
résultat des courses pour pour se mettre
dans le bain notre pouvoir d'achat va
être ravagé nos services publics vont
coûter beaucoup plus cher quand on va
est obligé de se faire soigner ça m'a
coûté beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus
cher quand on va être obligés d'acheter
notre énergie ça va coûter beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus cher donc la
réindustrialisation industrialisation de
la france fin mai mais est ce
qu'entendre c'est celle eux aussi la
conséquence de ce que je te disais tout
à l'heure de de la fin du droit de
propriété pourquoi veux tu quelqu'un
aujourd'hui investissent en france alors
qui sait que à tout moment on peut lui
fermer sa société parce que parce que tu
n'es pas d'accord avec avec monsieur
maquereau ou celui qui remplacera bien
sur mac là je peux faire un parallèle si
c'est une boîte qui financé par du
pognon d'état russe ces mêmes pognon que
sévit la guerre qu'ils n'étaient pas
financés par l'état ça fait 20 ans qu'il
était sorti de russie il avait eu qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient la preuve qu'avec
chelsea
le lioran oui le pauvre gars qui a dit
que les frères avec cette histoire c'est
qu'il est plus relayeur que ce sont les
ukrainiens qui avait fondé il ya une
douzaine d'ukrainiens multimilliardaire
qui mue à l'ombre personnes en rien cela
ils ont volé des dizaines de milliards
de dollars personne n'en parle non mais
encore une fois il faut faire
c'est pas c'est pas bien être là aussi
on joue avec son sexe du piano qu' il a
pu gagner des milliards n'ont pas
réaliste
et bien non non non il a des dizaines de
millions mais
c'est autre chose mais encore une fois
il ya quelque chose d'essentiel que vous
parlez de la réindustrialisation
la marge brute d'autofinancement des
entreprises françaises c'est à dire
grosso modo
c'est vous vous regardez combien restent
au milieu une fois que vous avez tous
payés comme ils vous avez vendu vous
regardez combien ça s'appelle la marge
brute c'est grosso modo le profit allez
va pas être bon et la moitié de ce
qu'elle est en allemagne à la moitié de
calais en angleterre donc si vous êtes
dans une industrie vous allez mettre une
usine en france faut être con comme à
nos
gymnastes grands fous mis la qualité de
vie en france nos paysages nos vaches
laitières d'odile tarder ça a pris 7
heures et puis nous tarde ya peu d'huile
à venir puisque vous dites ça la france
pour la première fois dans son histoire
est devenue déficitaire en produits
agricoles faut le faire quand même
comment at on réussi à [__] en l'air
la paysannerie française qui était et
qui faisait l'admiration des foules vous
vous balader partout en france et tous
les 15 km tout change architecture la
bouffe les hôtels et les chemises et les
églises
l'agneau d'agneau de change par tous est
un pays mais immensément divers et on a
eu cette imbécile de chirac avec sa
politique agricole commune qui en
l'espace de trente un foutu de la france
en en
maintenant les est ce que font les
paysans c'est qu'ils voient plus les
papiers pour pour des subventions aimé
et donc vous vous dites mais comment
vous faites les gars pour comment at on
réussi à transformer la france en un
pays qui importe de la nourriture et
vous pouvez m'expliquer comment c'est
possible mais c'est même pas je n'arrive
même pas à comprendre et du colza
c'est pour faire rouler les voitures
alors je vous arrête de seconde quand je
vous entends je trouve ça quand même un
petit peu très noir cc
c'est pas une question de noirci voir
les choses en face c'est savoir les
choses enfin c'est que la seule ville
avait deux façons d'organiser une
société où vous fondez l'organisation
sur la liberté de chacun des maires
d'anzhi chat c'est à dire que vous tout
le monde tout le monde se débrouiller et
c est ça c'est marche ou vous organisez
la contrainte donc à me disais mon
professeur d'économie à toulouse ya bien
longtemps il veilla que deux formes
d'organisation ou si la main visible
adam smith ou sept grands coups de pied
dans le derrière de salim mais rien
entre les deux et ça fait 25 30 ans 40
ans que les coups de pied au derrière de
staline remplace petit à petit la magie
d'un adam smith donc ici me lasse pas
c'est ce qui s'est passé en union
soviétique qui ce qui s'est passé l'an
chine ils ont été obligés de retourner à
la main invisible est donc encore une
fois il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
de rendre la liberté au jour le jour on
rendra la liberté aux français la libère
la france se redressera en cinq minutes
on n'a pas besoin de l'année j'ai pas
besoin qu'on prenne des mesures je veux
simplement qu'on me foute la paix c'est
quand même compréhensible non j'ai pas
besoin de demander je vous raconte une
histoire qui est extraordinaire pendant
la crise de 2008 2009 quel était le
problème mais le problème c'est qu'il y
avait une énorme et la crise de l'euro
en particulier 2012 il y avait des gens
qui avaient peur que l'euro sont
programmés des obligations italiennes et
ils pouvaient pas se couvrir
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas y
revenir mais n'y avait pas il n'y avait
pas de mécanisme qui permettait la
couverture avec un comics pixels mais
qui disent bien ration six nations avait
bien sûr être n'y avait pas de mécanisme
pour se couvrir contre le risque que
l'italie quitte le roman alors mon fils
pont un grand article dans le wall
street journal
disons pas à laëtitia là j'étais très
fier et j'ai pris et l'article et le
type d'article dit tranquillement il
suffit simplement que les banques
centrales européennes vendent des
options de vente sur la sur la dette
italienne
et assume le risque au cas où l'italie
saute comme ça les gens pourront
découvrir dès le moment où il pourra
ainsi couvrir il sait sont dans de la
dette italienne
non
c'était
s'appelait toute exécution le consul de
france et hong kong qui était un type
astucieux savent au poste d'ambassadeur
le consul français ont concédé un point
important ils étaient les phases de mr
des finances il dit il faut qu'il faut
vous interviewez ségala au directeur
général du trésor il faut que la
bienvenue parce qu'il ya un gars qui a
une idée intéressante
donc réunion direction générale du
trésor soul avec le chef du trader qui
mènera la bba la bce
et un monfils présente son plan
le type l'écoutent elle et lui dit mais
enfin monsieur si ça vous peuvent si ça
pouvait marcher nous en aurions eu
l'idée
de se dire la france a inventé parce
qu'on est des battles les taux d'intérêt
à terme en france à sa pleine matif
le matif le donc on a inventé les
positions à terme a commencé à jouer
comme des fous sur le matif c'était
marrant comme tout
qu'est ce qui s'est passé les gars qui
devait expliquer la chose sur le matif
verifone gagner de l'argent gros comme
et c'était insupportable au ministère
des finances donc ils ont mis des
réglementations n'en plus finir et tout
le marché obligataire la place qui
aurait dû contrôler les peaux les
mouvements mondiaux des marchés
obligataires seraient dues être pareil
parce qu'on est bourré de matheux et ben
s'ils ont tous partis à londres vous
allez à l'ombre dans toutes les places
les grandes maisons plus loin il ya des
gaulois ou des indiens mais maintenant
ils commençaient à voir quelques rustre
qui s'endettent qui sont des peuples
matin qu'est ce que vous lui fasse ces
types faut pas oublier que on a viré les
protestants qui j'ai réalisé que lui qui
j'étais très bon je dirais les provinces
et les protestants sous louis xiv après
avoir eu à gérer le produira les
protestants on et tous les aristos après
avoir viré en navire est tous les
problèmes personnels des délits d écoles
et d en 1890 là on avait fermé toutes
les écoles religieuses et après ça on a
viré tous les juifs tous les 40 50 ans
les français vieillir tout leurs élites
parce que l'élite au sommet ne supporte
pas la concurrence dégâts
donc on a une espèce de heaslip
imbéciles qui ne pensent qu'à garder le
contrôle de l'état ils prennent comme
davis que ces gens là quand même parce
que quand je voyais ça fait très
longtemps qu'on n'aura pas coupé la tête
on devrait donc en a bien sûr une petite
des opérations en place de grève ça
serait bien c'est que marquez qui les
barbares oui mais c'est efficace c'est
le foot c'est
sexy m'agace parce que tu en entends
plus parler pendant un moment il ya très
peu de gens qui prend des décisions
possibles là pour emmerder les autres
c'est que tout ce qu'on veut mais des
risques parce que les matières premières
alimentaires 0 trouvera bouffer ils ont
non mais oui oui ben le
ressusciter le rôle du ce fonctionnaire
c'est quand même d'être lauga qui
distribue les tickets de rationnement
c'est là où il est là il est dans son
bonheur le plus total est-ce qu'on va
vers une période où il y aura des
tickets le thème oui
c'est vrai faire ni 1 et un paquet donc
tu auras sur l'essence sur heroes
prendra votre votre pass actional et on
vous dira monsieur gars vous avez cassé
ou deux
mois passés aux deux tu lé coeur avec
eux ils veulent supprimer liquide ils
veulent supprimer l'équipe pourquoi pour
contrôler encore plus donc tu vas avoir
tu n'auras plus comme moi un paiement de
ta carte est ton téléphone et à partir
de ce moment là bas tu auras si tu es si
tu es gentil situe si tu cries gloire
aux grands leaders tous les matins à
vente avant d'aller au boulot et bien tu
aura peut-être le droit d'avoir un
un ticket un ticket bouffe quoi le droit
pour nous apprendre qu'on me dira vous
avez déjà pris trois fois l'avion pour
new york cette année c'est beaucoup mon
avis non vous avez vous une parenthèse
comment vous positionner sur le
réchauffement climatique
tous les deux
il faut faire quelque chose il faut
attendre
il faut il faut c'est du néon ça chauffe
pas
il faut faire quoi ils sont finalement
il faut d'abord réfléchir oui il faut il
faut d'abord réfléchir je pense qu'on a
tous déjà réfléchi sur les choses dont
tu fais tu veux pas sûr du tout quand je
le vois ce que je lis quand je lis ce
que je vois et que la bande s est il ya
plusieurs questions qui composent la
première c'est yat-il réchauffement
climatique ou pas oui il ya un mouvement
automatique très bien très bien reçus
deuxièmement est il d'origine humaine
oui
il ya des tas de gens qui disent que non
et des certificats scientifique de très
grande qualité troisièmement kiki
ben je sais pas vous mais je peux vous
donner une liste noire ou trois je sais
pas il ya par exemple christian
gérondeau qui l'ancien et c'est
énormément sur les quais quand même un
corps des mines qu'il faut savoir de
quoi il parle le il a fait état de
calculer il dit tout ça c'est du pipeau
vous avez le patron le type qui était le
président de le de deux des recherches
nucléaires et scientifique à princeton
ancien patron de tout ce qui était
active indique du vient dire que pour
lui ça n'existe pas le troisième c'est
celui qui était responsable de l'analyse
du climat par la terminer en des
satellites aussi un américain il dit que
l'une des plus dures que soient
d'origine
entremont orphique donc dans quel état
de gens qui disent mais ce que vous
n'avez pas le droit de le dire et ça
c'est un truc très important c'est
qu'elle est la base de la société
scientifique c'est que vous avez le
droit d'émettre une hypothèse pour la
discuter c'est ça la base de la science
vous dites par exemple est ce que la
terre tourne autour du soleil ou est ce
que c'est le soleil qui tourne autour de
la terre hypothèse scientifique et
appartient moment où vous dites vous
n'avez pas le droit de poser cette
hypothèse vous sortez de la science pour
entrer dans la religion et donc sur ce
jeu sexuel réchauffement climatique ça
fait un petit moment qu'on est sorti de
la science pour entrer dans la religion
je n'ai pas le droit de poser un certain
nombre d'hypothèses que je testerai et à
la vci je suis de bonne foi à la fin je
dirais oui à la flèche matière éthique
et oui c'est nouvellement créé mais j'en
sais rien et la troisième fois ce qu'il
faut dire c'est ce que dit jon landau
qui est le grand spécialiste de te qui
est un dan - tout à fait à gauche et
tokyo mais les krills environ dans
l'environnement disent sceptiques qui
mettait un bouquin qui ont été scellées
et lui dit la troisième chose il faut
voir c'est est ce que les mesures
comprennent qu'on prend pour traiter ce
problème s'ils existent sont les bonnes
je lui lis mais pas du tout elles sont
affreuses donc vous donner trois
problèmes est ce qu'il existe deux kills
l'origine humaine et troisièmement est
ce qu'on prend les bonnes mesures et ce
qui est certain c'est que sur le
troisième ou s'étouffe ou 1 1 ça existe
il ya eu tous attendent il ya eu
d'autres réchauffement climatique en
l'histoire en 250 il y avait des vignes
en islande
et le groenland n'étaient pas couverts
de glace dont il ya eu des tas de
réchauffement climatique dans l'histoire
qui avait rien à voir avec lui aime
parce qu'elle n'est pas à l'époque à
part les pets des vaches qui avait pas
grande pas beaucoup de donc vous vous
êtes en train de dire que oui il ya
réchauffement climatique et qui est
serré mais c'est possible mais c'est
certainement pas le premier dans
l'histoire mais sauf que yahoo tropiques
mais vous êtes ce que vous dites mais
moi je sais rien
l'entropie gens se foutent rien su des
entreprises c'est à nous de sujets non
mais je veux dire par là il faut poser
les questions ce cas le risque est
certain c'est que les solutions qu'on a
pris c'est à dire la miroir magique et
les boules à avant ça ça marchera oui ça
c'est certain que les miroirs magiques
les
centrales au sommaire le truc qui
je peux encore j'ai pas de vieux os sur
la question ça fait 40 ans que lee
dessus et je me suis toujours pas faire
une opinion donc peu importe savoir si
si
si ça vient de l'humain pas le la vraie
question c'est c'est comment on règle le
problème est comment on règle le
problème en effet là on prend les choses
totalement à l'envers parce que ces
politiques parce que c'est dogmatique on
n'aime pas le nucléaire donc en fait ce
qu'on va faire c'est que les allemands
l'ont fait nous on est en train de le
faire on achète les voix des écolos
points ça va pas plus loin que ça c'est
pas c'est pas quelque chose de sain 2 2
voilà c'est mais non mais c'est même
plus que ça parce que en fait ce que le
le le tu peux pas ne pas être écolo tu
peux même pas être écolo c'est à dire je
vais dire en fait tu veux polluer la
planète
évidemment que tu vas me répond non tu
vas peut-être t'as pas envie de polluer
la palette donc donc si tu réponds non
si tu réponds oui j'ai j'ai envie de
polluer la planète tu sors c'est
tellement con comme réflexion que tu
sors et si c'est avec ça qu'ils jouent
et donc ce que c'est aujourd'hui il faut
être écolo parce que parce que les
jeunes vont voter pour toi parce que tu
vas prendre quelques voix extra qui vont
qui vont manquer ce qui est nécessaire
mais non mais en fait les gars ne
cherche pas du tout à régler le problème
dont qui y vont parce qu'on leur a dit
pendant des années le nucléaire c'est
pas bien donc et annoncent qu'ils vont
fermer toutes les usines clés oui mais
sauf que on ne peut pas tu ne peux pas
aujourd'hui avoir une énergie qui est
intermittente c'est à dire les panneaux
solaires et c'est à dire les
les éoliennes ça ne peut pas fonctionner
parce que qu'est ce qui va se passer la
nuit alors laisse donc la suivante
chaîne vous fais un truc qui va parler
de ça je rentre pas dans le détail donc
je vous ai fait venir pour parler
finances ges en et de la finance charles
ont certes charge globale était nuls q
oui nous sommes une société transformant
que notre pib cette énergie transformé
qu'est-ce qui se passe les marchés
financiers qui se tiennent tous par la
barbichette tous les produits financiers
sont intriqués
je vais vous donner un exemple je
m'amuse beaucoup vous regardez les uns
des
bleus cac n'importe quel à 10 le new
york stock exchange
le standard and poor prenez le cac
ça fait cinq six sept ans que je dis à
mes clients c'est pas difficile
de choisir une société en france mais
dans son portefeuille vous regardez si
l'état a ainsi annoncé une extension
s'il est à un siège au conseil
d'administration vous l'achetez pas
parce que ça va être géré n'importe
comment et donc j'ai identifié dix
valeurs à peu près en france qui n'ont
rien à voir les crétins bombe elle font
200 points de base de plus par an que
les que le reste du marché donc ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que vous avez
deux marchés à l'intérieur des marchés
des actions ce que j'appelle le marché
capitaliste où la rentabilité du capital
investi est l'élément déterminant et
vous avez l'autre le marché communiste
où c'est dans le fond le capitalisme de
connivence les coquins et les crapules
qui se met entre eux pour gagner du
pognon mais vous regardez comment ses
côtés il y en a elles et les sociétés
d'état ne cesse de baisser et des autres
ne cessent de monter donc ce que
j'essaie de dire que vous regardez vous
faites des indices est à mourir de rire
donc ça veut dire simplement
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez une classe qui
a des idées de piller la france toujours
cette classe au pouvoir et qui se sert
des instruments que l'état et qui au
travers des années pourpier pays et on
le voit très bien qu'il dise que
l'effondrement de l'ex union soviétique
ça s'est passé après ça s'est passé
quand les mesures seules critiques s'est
effondré à ce moment là il ya une
certaine série gears malin qu'on
appelait les oligarques qui ont acheté
des tas d'actions qui ont pris le
contrôle de sociétés l'allocution qu'il
contrôlait société est pris avant si
vous voulez regarder ce qu'on fait par
exemple a eu des airs c'est quand même
une fraude vous l'avez mentionné edf
d'amour vous mettez vingt ans en arrière
vous vous dites on va avoir des
problèmes d'énergie la france maîtrisent
la transformation d'uranium en énergie
la france maîtrisent le transfert de
l'électricité et la france maîtrisent la
construction de centrales nucléaires en
maîtrise tout en vain à temps on n'a
plus rien c'est fini madame alors sur le
lot des sauvageons lauvergeon le vélo à
foot a foutu en l'air l'uranium on sait
plus faire et vous allez voir
aujourd'hui des gens vous leur dites
c'est ce que je veux dire ils vont voir
les gars comprennent la retraite qui ont
64 ans disant parce qu'ils ne trouvent
plus d'ingénieurs nucléaires
ils ne trouvent plus il ya plus
maintenant il ya plus de type des arts
et métiers qui vont dans le nucléaire
parce que ça fait 30 ans qu'on leur dit
que ça va ça va se pt donc grosso modo
ce l'état a détruit le système nucléaire
français qui est l avantage qu'ont
apparent père actif qu'on avait par
rapport au reste du monde et tous ces
cons là me parle d' état stratège tout
le temps d'aimer l'état stratège il a
foutu en l'air le seul endroit où on
était compétitif
fallait le faire quand même est-ce que
vous avez vu les déclarations d'ailleurs
qui ce monsieur s'est fait au speed de
sa boîte le directeur des fonds le
directeur de l'investissement
responsable de hsbc
est-ce que vous avez vu ces déclarations
qui ont valu un bon gros coup de pied
aux fesses parce qu'il disait en gros le
les marchés
s'adapteront le réchauffement climatique
il faut pas s'en soucier les marchés
trouveront l'innovation pour pouvoir
pallier à tout ça pour vous c'est bien
c'est pas bien
est ce que le marché est toujours
j'avais un état être capable de diriger
quelque chose comme la demande d'énergie
parfois il a été utile dans l'offre
d'énergie par exemple
pompidou giscard de voulons créer le
nucléaire les encres et les duclair mais
la demande d'énergie c'est relier un
point avec la croissance économique et
j'ai vu un papier de la commission
européenne qui est sorti à 6,9 mois que
j'ai lu il annonce tranquillement que la
demande d'énergie de l'europe va baisser
de 27% ganassi fossiles d'énergie en
tout il y met tous 27% dans les quarante
ans qui viennent mais ça veut dire que
le pib a baissé de 27% c'est à dire
qu'ils programment une baisse du niveau
de vie comme on a faim ma question je
reviens avec du monde donc l'énergie les
marchés financiers les fonds de pension
ce qui est certain c'est que si on fait
pas
plus que je suis dans les marchés
puisque vous parlez des questions vous
pouvez faire un indice des valeurs
fossiles et puis vous faites un indice
des valeurs subventionné vous savez des
miroirs magiques et s'est enquis son
côté aussi un
élu miroir magique et les moulins à vent
la d2 son côté et vous regardez ce
qu'elles ont fait depuis
2012 ça va faire dix ans
l'énergie et les total et ses cdo et les
hôtels sont tout en bas c'est à dire que
les marchés ne croient pas une seconde
que les solutions qui ont été retenus
par les états c'est comme les vaccins il
ya eu des milliards et des milliards qui
ont été payées pour les vaccins de
pfizer le poignant pas été perdu pour
tout le monde je suis bien certain qu'il
ya des gens autour de madame van der
leyen ne sait pas quand même s'ils ont
dû toucher des commissions lors pas dû
être triste ça c'est à supputations ça
c'est bien sûr c'est la supputation mais
je quand je vois quatre milliards de
dollars il ya quatre milliards de doses
de vaccins qui ont été achetés qui ne
servent à rien
qui va payer c'est pas mal comme lille
qui est signée le cema la mandarine
revenons marchés financiers et
l'adaptation des marchés financiers s'il
ya des baisses de pib de 30% dans les
pays occidentaux
comment vous faire les fonds de pension
pour payer les retraites des
fonctionnaires une plombe
tranquille
on peut par et on peut pas être dans le
rêve tout le temps on peut pas être dans
le miracle suspense et le
super jeune tu as des tu as des fonds de
pension qui sont déjà à l'agonie alors
que les marchés étaient quasiment au
plus haut tu penses bien que si
maintenant les marchés se casse la
figure de 80% ils vont faire quoi les
fonds de pension sachant qu'en plus la
plupart des fonds de pension qui
n'obtenaient plus rien de la partie
obligataire sont allés se mettre sûr sûr
sûr des saloperies qui ne valent rien
qui ont un prix en général très élevé
mais une valeur qui vaut aux héros et
qui vont prendre très très cher et à ce
moment là bas qu'est ce qu'on fera on
fera ce que font déjà certains fonds de
pension par exemple aux états unis où on
dit bah ouais les gars mais on vous
paiera que le tiers de ce que de ce
qu'on vous avait annoncé parce que parce
qu'il ya plus et puis y'a pus et culte
hier et que on se tape une inflation à
deux chiffres ça va faire mal d'accord
si j'avais été dans le déni que je tends
aujourd'hui on est on est dans le déni
il ya plein de gens qui disent ah mais
oui mais finalement ça n'arrivera pas
mais l'état s'en occupent non l'état il
s'occupe de rien l'état aujourd'hui il
est en panique il est en mode
fuite en avant perpétuelle
alors ça tiens ça tiens ça craque ou y
un peu à droite à gauche sauf que à
chaque fois on ne change pas le modèle
on ne réfléchit pas sur un autre modèle
ce qu'on fait si on met des patchs c'est
que face à un tsunami tu peux mettre ton
petit sac de sable c'est ça qui va
changer essayez de réfléchir comment
c'est réfléchir avec la communauté ont
recommencé 2
le rapport du giec et spécialement la
partie de vallière 6,20 masson-delmotte
les pentes et serbie nous espérons faire
mais c'est pas comme si je l'avais pas
lu mais le gia qui a les scientifiques
qui font un énorme travail et puis
ensuite il ya un résumé qui est fait
pour les politiques et qui est fait par
des politiques et qui n'a rien à voir
avec le travail qui est fait à
l'extérieur de l'autre côté donc si vous
les logiques c'est un outil qui est qui
a été monté par un canadien il ya très
longtemps l'intérieur des nations unies
de façon à essayer d'arriver un
gouvernement mondial parce que puisque
c'est un problème mondial il faut qu'on
ait des solutions mondiales ce qui est
un coup sauf s'il ya pas de problème on
se retrouve avec un gouvernement mondial
mais est ce que vous croyez qu'ils
gouvernent mondiale sera plus capable de
régler le problème que la bruxelles
on a eu à bruxelles une harmonisation
des câbles usb dont pouvoir charger les
téléphones oui j'aime bien conçu mais
moi ce que j'ai vu à bruxelles si vous
voulez c'est que par exemple comme un
d'amman merkel a décidé de fermer les
centrales nucléaires elle n'a pas
demandé l'avis des autres elle a fermé
comme ça et alors qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand il fait froid en
allemagne et brûlent les charbons ces
couillons la bombe du charbon très bien
mais quand le vent vient du nord-est il
arrive chez nous et alors qu'est ce qui
se passe à paris on a de la poussière de
charbon qui tombe et qu'est ce que fait
madame hidalgo elles arrêtent les
voitures
ça permet d'ouvrir des boîtes qui font
des masques qui permet de filtrer que
gentil vie mais je veux dire c'est quand
même extraordinaire moi si j'avais été
le gouvernement français j'aurais dû aux
allemands vont voitures elles sont
faites avec une énergie polluante je
vous mets 1000 euros de surcharge sur
toutes les dames w les mercenaires c'est
dégueulasse que vous faites mais mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais mais mais
voiturettes sont faites avec de
l'énergie propre il n'y a pas de raison
qu'on arrête paris parce que les
allemands brûler du charbon à 1500km
rapport du gic
bien sûr la bande de gaza derrière
distrait comme john mes amis mais la
partie 2-2
masson delmotte aussi de profondeur
celui-ci d'ailleurs vous conseille la
vidéo c'est pas mal mais il ya sûrement
des gars ya sûrement des gars qui sont
compétents là dedans mais je ne connais
pas un seul modèle j'ai bâti des modèles
toute ma vie qui peut expliquer le
climat de l'an dernier moi j'ai bâti des
modèles ou en général j'étais capable de
l'expliquer ce qui s'était passé dans le
marché avant les derniers modèles jugés
konami nous annonce et les canicules
mustaq la canicule il fait un froid de
canard ans il fait un froid de canard je
sais pas par exemple à à vancouver il
fit 55,2 au pakistan quand même c'est
peut-être il fait peut-être au pakistan
mais c'est parce que leur admission mais
encore une fois succès ça n'est pas une
preuve ok ça dépasse et dresser pas
parce que vous crever tout au pakistan
moi j'étais au pakistan ou crevaison
tout le temps pakistan wei a crevé de
chou il trouve et je sais ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure le problème vous
avez à 0,26 à ses origines ni même pas
se battre sur le fait qu' que peu se
soient d'origine humaine au pays mais
c'est sur les sur le chou ces structures
sont pas les jeunes et les solutions
sont pas les bonnes donc à partir de là
si tu veux cette espèce de truc là on y
sont tous partis sur 0-0 nucléaire c'est
juste pas possible
donc essayons réfléchir autrement il ya
des choses qui sont qui met d'abord
qu'il aurait fallu faire malheureusement
il ya il ya 15 ans et
là parce qu'il ya les élections il y a
on ferme fessenheim et puis et puis de
trois jours plus tard macron nous
annonce qui va construire je ne sais
combien de deux centrales il fermer
fessenheim ya un an et puis quand il ya
la crise énergétique que moi j'annonce à
l'atome est criant depuis deux ans dix
ans c'est les prix du pétrole vont
monter à 200 et là il se rend compte que
ça arrive c'est à dire que peut il avait
rien compris et à ce moment-là il dit on
va faire des centrales nucléaires mais
si le prix du pétrole redescend en
baisse à 89 semaine prochaine il les
fera pas ses centrales nucléaires donc
je veux dire ça n'est que des effets
d'annoncé
pas de modification mais s'ils voulaient
la grande différence c'est que quand il
y avait de gaulle je vais dire un truc
c'était grosso modo des corps des mines
qui faisait le plan c d'année mais des
mecs qui savait faire une règle de trois
et des ingénieurs qui étaient quand même
un niveau incroyable les guerreaux etc
c'était autre chose et maintenant c'est
des inspecteurs des finances dans le but
la formation c'est de vérifier la
comptabilité de la préfecture de brive
mais il s'agit ici connaissent rien en
sciences on a plus de gens qui prennent
des décisions sur une base scientifique
ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui dans les
cabinets ministériels il ya des haches
et c où il ya des des sciences po où il
ya des inspecteurs des finances mais où
sont les corps des mines qui était le
coeur de l'industrie française 101
finances ils ont tous en train de faire
des calculs à la con à l'ombre pour
gagner de l'argent sur les marchés
obligataires
mais sérieux c'est vrai là pour des
questions de réchauffement climatique il
va falloir qu'on baisse au dessous de
notre production de co2 notre capacité à
capter de la flotte un peu partout ainsi
de suite
d'accord est ce que les marchés
financiers peuvent supporter et résister
à une baisse de consommation énergétique
de troisième chose qui compte c'est pour
les marchés financiers c'est la
rentabilité marginale du capital investi
c'est le rôle des marchés financiers de
mesurer combien de gagner si vous mettez
un euro plus en investissement que si
vous l'avez pas mais bon si vous
acceptez cette définition il est très
certain qu'il va y avoir des secteurs à
cause de ça peut-être si c'est
nécessaire qu'ils vont regagner de
l'argent gros comme et des secteurs qui
vont s'effondrer
parce que ils seront continuera à
bouffer délégué l'énergie et c'est donc
le rôle des marchés financiers s'est pas
de prendre une décision c'est d'envoyer
le capital là où il sera utilisé
intelligemment mais comme ils font tout
pour empêcher sa part des dix par des
interventions administratives et des
réglementations à la con et bien vous
allez je vois pas comment ça va marcher
les marchés financiers font très bien
leur boulot sur le laisse tranquille
n'a plus de marchés financiers
aujourd'hui tu es dans des prix
administrés depuis 10 ans tuée dans une
logique de près annie serait donc cesser
les banques centrales qui fixe les prix
du pétrole mais
c'est les banques centrales qui fixe le
prix des taux d'intérêt c'est les
banques centrales qui fixe les prix
aussi de certaines actions puisque l on
achète et des des indices
des différents indices de actions des
différents pays donc à partir de ce
moment là si tu n'as plus le marché
puisque c'est un régime un marché c'est
un endroit où tu as une confrontation d
offre et de la demande et puis ça te
fait un prix informations voilà les
informations et le cidre ont pris le
pôle pressée de systèmes d'information
de l'entrepreneur donc si vous avez des
prix vous pouvez prendre des décisions
qui sont rationnels à partir du moment
où vous savez que les prix sont faux
c'est comme les informations données par
les izvestia ou la pravda vous savez que
c'est faux vous n'allez pas prendre des
décisions là dessus donc grosso modo le
seul prix qu'ils sont vrais aujourd'hui
dans le marché c'est des prix d'énergie
tout le tout ou pas de l'or non
maintenant parce que l'homme alors vous
savez il est manipulé par les banques
centrales qui s'amusent comme des folles
avec saint céré ou de l'argent c'est
pareil parce qu'elles veulent pas
laisser monter l'or parce qu'elle pense
que ça donnerait la une panique sur les
marchés des actions d'aurizon d'ailleurs
mais occupe toi donc en fait le seul
vrai prix aujourd'hui c'est le prix de
l'énergie en grèce et son marché en fait
ça concerne que le pétrole le reste
c'est des prix administrés donc
et tu verras que le jour où et c'est
bien c'est bien le problème des banques
centrales aujourd'hui c'est que elles
savent très bien que si elle arrête
d'administrer les prix c'est à dire si
elle arrête la planche à billets si elle
arrête les quantitative easing
réellement
marchés s'effondrent puisque c'est plus
elle qui contrôle et à ce moment là tu
vas revenir à la vraie valeur la vraie
valeur elle risque comme on a perdu
toute notion et ça depuis dix ans de ce
que peut être la vraie valeur des choses
ça risque d'être saignant warren buffett
c'était quand même à l'investisseur de
génie sur les dernières soixante dix
années il est un marché baissier c'est
le moyen par lequel la capitale retourne
à son vrai propriétaire
[Musique]
de la communauté les marchés font bien
leur boulot quand on les laisse faire
votre phrase la crise des subprimes a
montré le contraire mais non c'est le
contraire c'était une crique intégrer
toutes pièces par les états
puisque l'état avait fixé le taux
d'intérêt à des niveaux débile donc tout
je veux dire les états avaient mis des
taux d'intérêt à des niveaux aux héros
dont il ya toute une série dian comme on
l'a fait à faire des produits à la con
pourrait pour monter un dd des systèmes
des dizaines de structures et puis tout
ça ça ne serait jamais passé si les taux
d'intérêt étaient des niveaux nombre
jamais alors j'écris tout d'un livre là
tu vous pouvez le lire si vous voulez
quelque chose d'intéressant c'est que ce
n'appelle libérale et non coupable
les les culs de la moitié 60 % je crois
des subprimes ont été fabriqués entre le
deuxième semestre
2006 et le 1er semestre 2007 ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que à ce moment
là bernanke y était à la tête de la fed
au lieu de
rouler au lieu de faire monter les taux
est de continuer à faire monter les taux
ils arrêtent de les monter et donc là
c'est fait c'est fait c'est à dire qu'on
brasse du subprime à qui mieux mieux ce
qui avait un litige de dynamiser le
marché de l'immobilier aux états unis en
ce deal a permis de planter le marché de
l'immobilier le planter non je vous
donne un exemple qui est assez simple
normalement dans un système capitaliste
mais tant que la rentabilité marginale
du capital investi soit à 4 les uns donc
normalement les seuls qui devrait
pouvoir emprunter c'est ceux qui ont une
rentabilité supérieure à 4
d'accord donc vous mettez les taux à 4
il ya que ceux qui peuvent emprunter qui
sont à 4 et puis vous avez toute une
société sur les sociétés qui sont 1 3 2
3 1 de rendement maintenant si vous
mettez les taux d'intérêt à zéro comme
l'avait fait cet imbécile de bernanke et
où comme l'a fait madame jelen
après et c'est là qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est que les gens qui vont emprunter ne
vont pas emprunter pour acheter une
nouvelle machine ou bâtira devant
l'autel ils vont acheter s'ils peuvent
emprunter à 0 pour acheter une
entreprise qui gagne du 2 au 10 3% en
prenant du levier c'est comme ça ils
vont gagner l'argent on pourrait
arracher des actifs donc quand vous
mettez les taux d'intérêt très bas ça
fait monter le prix des actifs mais
comme plus personne investie dans
l'économie réelle ça veut dire que la
productivité du travail baisse donc les
riches deviennent plus riches parce que
les actifs monte et les pauvres
deviennent plus pauvres
mais le bel la dette augmente de façon
exponentielle
et quand la dette s'écroule ce que dit
tout le monde à ce moment là avec un air
fierro c'est vous voyez bien que le
capitalisme ne marche pas et c'est parce
qu'ils ont foutu le prix du kg le bruit
du capital info prix donc c'est pas le
capitalisme qui est qui et qui marche
pas c'est ce corniaud de bernanke est
une bonne amie nl donc encore une fois
arrêtons de mélanger des choses ce qui
ne marche pas c'est la banque centrale
quand j'avais rencontré de l'habitat de
friedman chapeau compterait plusieurs
reprises il m'avait dit la première des
choses qu'il faut faire c'est supprimer
les banques centrales
il faut supprimer les banques centrales
cédées malfaiteurs
christine lagarde vous en pensez quoi
belle elle est promue à son niveau des
compétences mais il montre son arrêt
principe de peter c saint principe de
péter en mai bien pur parce qu'elle
continue la promo elle a été informée
télé nationale elle a perdu 80 milliards
de dollars en cinq minutes en les
prêtant l'argentine alors que tout le
monde lui avait dit tu peux le faire et
elle a été immédiatement produit une
promu à la bce où elle va en perdre des
centaines de mineurs le jour où l'euro
disparaître donc je voulais c'est quand
même un truc merveilleux c'est
le rookie disparaît
monsieur sapin connaissez monsieur sympa
il nous est il nous a parlé d'un truc
qui s'appelle le fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires garantis jusqu'à 72
mille euros par contre est taillé par
établissement et que tous ceux qui ont
plus de temps sur son compte en banque
ont reçu un fameux petit papier comme
quoi leur travail et leur argent était
protégé par le fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires quand monsieur sapin
s'est rendu compte que certains comme
vous c'est quand même le fonds de
garantie des dépôts bancaires s'est
approvisionné combien donc ça fait
combien de comptes en banque qui sont
garanties là ils sont rendus compte que
bon l'effet de manche ne fonctionnait
pas il a dit l'état grâce à sa signature
pour à démultiplier le fonds de garantie
des dépôts bancaires
d'accord donc la question je vous pose
c'est si l'euro se montre si nos banques
a des petits problèmes
est ce que le fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires c'est pas un petit peu
le pansement sur une jambe de bois pour
assurer tout c'est même à avancement
c'est là qu'on laissera on les écoute
les sera saigné
temps qu il faudra faire mais on le fera
pas en suède il en rit 192 la suède a
sauté en 92 le peu johnson la suède a
sauté j'étais dans le bureau du
gouverneur de la banque centrale le jour
où ça saute et c'était un cadeau l'inde
où c'était en automne il était intrigué
et je rigole pas mais qu'est ce qu'ils
ont fait lécher les doigts car les
banques ont sauté ils ont garanti les
dépôts de thonon personne qui avait un
dépôt ne souffrira mais par contre les
actionnent les actionnaires sont passés
à zéro et un certain nombre de
présidents de banques qui ont été en
prison et cinq ans après il
réintroduisez les banques dans le marché
des actions eelv et six fois la mise
donc skiff mais vous allez pas mettre en
prison des inspecteurs des finances à la
libération il y en a aucun qui a été
mise en prison il s'est rien passé ils
ont tous été promu donc encore une fois
si vous voulez vous avez une classe
protéger regardez quand on a eu la
grande crise de 2008 2009 pour la
première fois de l'histoire des crises
financières il n'y a pas eu à gagner aux
états unis en grande bretagne et en
france qui a été en taule
pas
si vous dire l'espèce de
2 comment dire de
l'absence de possibilité de mettre ces
gens là en examen
moi ce qui me sidère c'est le fait que
tous ces gens là ils ne leur arrive
jamais rien ils sont promis au truculent
regarde l ancien ministre de la santé
elle est provenu immédiatement à la
l'organisation mondiale de la santé à
genève où sais pas quoi et donc il ya
une classe qui s'est organisé une espèce
d'amnisty permanente il peut rien leur
arriver jamais
non mais
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de
garanties qu'elle quelle soit tu
sauteras ces toupies grâce qui
assure-t-on compter tu sauteras
fermera les banques exactement ce qui
s'est passé au liban aura la même chose
en france dans après me demande pas la
date j'en sais rien mais ça devrait ça
devrait plus tard sauter les banques il
suffit simplement de dire aux gambier
côté non mais par ça devrait le faire le
capital des banques ceux qui ont acheté
des actions des banques ou des
obligations des banques savent à 0
et les appréhensions bon d'ailleurs que
nationaliser le système bancaire il ment
s'il si la perte est trop trop
importante ils n'ont pas le choix donc
une question qui était passé sur le tce
il faut partir ouf
déjà en dehors de l'union européenne ce
serait pas mal ça fait déjà ça fait déjà
quelques problèmes qu'ils sont mais le
problème c'est aujourd'hui le problème
c'est que c'est que c'est le monde
antique est géré comme ça c'est à dire
que c'est la même chose aux etats unis
c'est la même chose au canada c'est la
même chose tu allais même temps les
mêmes partout et qui utilise les mêmes
méthodes au final donc finalement ta
pâte a pas tellement de tapas tellement
d'endroits où où ce bail alors
moi je pense que là la suisse est encore
un pays qui est démocratique avec avec
des banques qui sont solides parce que
c'est des banques privées parce qu'il
n'ya pas elles ne sont pas dans le
circuit bancaire généralistes que tu
connais bnp compagnie s'était général et
autres donc
qu'ils sont qui sont solides et qui
permettront peut-être quand vous vous
dire qu'ils sont solides aussi lancia
nom des solides si tu veux on sait très
bien que les banques et banques
européennes aujourd'hui je vais te je
vais te refaire le 1 le truc en plus
avec la récession qui arrive donc tu vas
avoir pas mal d'obligations qui seront
jamais remboursées pas mal de dettes qui
ne seront jamais remboursés et une
banque aujourd'hui
européenne c'est ces 50 milliards de
fonds propres 1500 milliards d'actifs et
35 mille milliards de positions sur les
marchés dérivés donc fin de l'histoire
quoi on sait que ça va sauter à un
moment on sait que ça va faire très mal
parce que ça sera pas une autre la sujet
c'est à la kerviel ça sera soit les 5
milliards ça sera à jour un gros pépin
donc voir ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'en
plus ils ont une grosse partie de leurs
fonds propres qui sont dans des
obligations d'état mais oui
donc c'est vraiment lequel le chat qui
se mord la queue donc on sait que c'est
bon mais là des finances mur ces banques
là vont avoir un pépin c'est évident or
comme elles sont aujourd'hui grosse très
grosse
interconnectés et cetera cd montant
extraordinaire bien tu sais qu'un jour
tu vas avoir un énorme pépin et que là
monsieur sapin avec ses 72 me valent un
truc important va être va être
produits dérivés c'est quand même il
faut savoir c'est le système d'assurance
dans le système des capitalistes vous
allez changer d vous échangez des
quantités contre des prix et puis vous
avez le futur qui rentrent en jeu donc
si vous pouvez vendre des futurs en
acheter que vous couvrir et c'est ce que
fait une entreprise et là il ya tout
dans le 6ème cabinet ce que les gens ne
comprennent jamais sait qui est le
système des prix aux pâtes etc et puis
vous avez tout un système d'assurance et
de réassurance et dans le fond tous ces
produits dérivés dans tout le monde
passe par chez nous c'est le petit bard
chemin syrie en a partout et ça se passe
et c'est extraordinairement compliquée
personnes et qu'enfin une chatte n'y
retrouverait pas ses petits mais
s'attend ça marche et donc le système
des produits dérivés par construction
système à somme nulle c'est à dire que
air france s'assure auprès d'euros ce
nest pour le pétrole eros naissent sur
auprès de chez pâquis pour la livraison
du pétrole et puissance s'insurge suis
voilà donc c'est un système qui est le
principal ges annuel donc c'est comme si
vous disiez il ya des milliards et des
milliards qui sont d'un risque dans le
domaine des maisons en france qui sont
assurées oui mais enfin bon qu'elles
sont toutes en même temps et général le
vrai danger si j'ai quelqu'un intervient
avec des grosses paluches et casse la
chaîne c'est-à-dire 2 meuros messe avec
armentières france qu'il vendrait du
pétrole à 60 et puis on travaille plus
mais cros n'est-ce donc maintenant la
france doit aller dans le marché se
couvrir à 140 convoi 130 et ça c'est ce
qui s'est passé quand angie a sauté dans
2008 2009 c'est à dire que c'était un
des plus gros réassureurs et il se
retrouvait alors que votre course et
c'est là le gouvernement est intervenu
pour ans pour empêcher sa mère non sans
avoir fait sauter d'abord de lehman
brothers qui était une imbécillité donc
moi ce qui me fait très peur aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui sont aux
commandes qui comprennent pas ce système
ce système de rassurance qui est
extraordinairement subtil des donations
cela est acquis il faut [__] une paix
royale quoi et donc c'est ça qui me
terrifie si j'ai mis 6 intervienne avec
leurs gros d'euros poilus graisseux dans
cette histoire là ils peuvent déclencher
un cataclysme sans même comprendre
pourquoi quoi c'est ça qui met qui
m'étonne le plus c'est par exemple quand
on a décidé d'arrêter des transactions
avec la russie là
le dimanche matin grandes déclarations
de l'europe dix ans on
travaille plus aucune
donc riche très bien
dimanche 5 1 dans l'après midi ben oui
mais finalement on va travailler quand
même avec deux banques russes seuls qui
sont très actifs sur le marché du
pétrole à terme était d'érable parce que
c'est elle qui faisait la couverture
donc les mecs ils ont passé l'ordre le
matin depuis travaillé et il ya
probablement la dot jeu et la bnp qui
ont téléphoné au gardien
que si un peu plus de ram et des
crotenay ces six en or pas leur truc
nous ressentons ils sont là à 5 heures
panique générale n'ont finalement ce
n'est
donc vous dire mais les gars qui ont
pris la décision de tout arrêter avec
les banques russes le dimanche matin il
n'était pas au courant non parce qu'ils
ont jamais bossé sur à manger
financement donc ils ne savent pas ils
ne savent pas de
problème c'est ça c'est qu'ils savent
pas mais donc on est géré par des
incompétents
d'ailleurs la garonne les résultats
qu'on
savait des solutions quand même le
solutionner a pas d'autre solution que
de revenir au prix de marché déserté par
une rose constant vaut mieux une fin
horrible
vous savez c'est le proverbe allemand
ils sont 76 à des stades allemands
toujours des trucs il vaut mieux une fin
horrible qu une horreur sans fin
donc on n'a fait que des conneries
depuis 30 ans l'union soviétique a fait
dit que des conneries pendant 70 ans à
un moment ils ont du monde c'est fini le
gain on peut plus retourner à l'arbre et
à la réalité
donc on vit dans un monde magique je me
tue à vous le dire
ça fait 25 ans 30 ans 40 ans qu'on vit
dans un monde magique à faire croire aux
gens que créer de l'argent c'est créer
de la valeur ce qui n'est pas vrai il ya
aucun rapport à la création de valeur la
création d'argent
il faut s'attacher à la création de
valeur et ne pas essayer de noyer les
gens se détendre ou d'argent bon là on
il faut vous faire un peu rêver quand
même un peu à me donner un petit peu
moins large de personnes si les jeux de
quizz maintenant je vais vous dire ce
qui est merveilleux merveilleux
merveilleux je vais vous expliquer ça
merveilleux qui merveilleux d'ailleurs
c'est que la chute de l'union soviétique
s'apprêtait à une mauvaise nouvelle pour
les rucks ils sont beaucoup mieux
aujourd'hui 45 ans ils ont quand même
pris très très hachée en 90 ans
ont partagé des vrais gens qui
manqueront pas la gueule ça fait douze
sur trente ans a fait 14 ans qu'on dit
ça fait 14 ans qu'on se prend qu'on ce
qu'on se fait
insulter sur les réseaux et ces rapaces
qu'on dit ce qui va se passer ça fait 14
ans qu'on nous dit oui toutes façons de
la marche à chaque fois qu'il ouvre la
bouche c'est pour dire des horreurs ex
ah ouais d'accord sauf que maintenant
les gars va falloir payer l'addition
c'est tout c'est tout ce que je dis
depuis ça fait 14 ans que je dis il ya
no free lunch donc qu paiera l'addition
tu peux pas aller au restaurant vous
fait comme un cochon et jamais payé on
t'a portent l'addition et c'est
maintenant qu'on est bien celle d'il ya
aussi autre chose il n'y a pas de
solution collective parce que
collectivement on va ramasser une claque
mais chacun des gens qui nous écoutent
peut prendre des décisions vous arrêtiez
d'organiser son épingle de la façon là
où ils se ruent l'apprendra - plein la
gueule c'est pour ça que j'ai dû au
chant par ailleurs moi je me marre ce
jour parce que les gens disent c'est
toujours écouter si vous avez pas quoi
faire on achète d'air liquide parce
qu'ils produisent partout ils font des
produits dans tout le monde a besoin et
vous regardez en liquide ça fait un
siècle qui seront ils vendent partout
ils produisent partout vous prendrez 50%
vous avez 20 ans en 1900 aller en 1920
en allemagne vous avez fait la guerre de
14 ans avait survécu au couteau vous
voulez faire votre retraite pour 1960
vous acheter des obligations de l'ong
save à 0 2 fois un terrible
vous achetez de l'or on vous met dans un
camp de concentration parce qu'on vous
le pic etc vous acheter du mobilier il
est bombardé il respirait ce qu'ils
risquent des gravats vous achetez ims
vous achetez y est farben et vous
acheter d'autres banques et vous prenez
votre retraite tranquille de l'armement
non vous achetez simplement tg des
actions de sociétés bien gérées
et vous vous dites ils s'occuperont de
moi si on fait revenir l'inflation ne
réplique pas
et vont plus avoir son compte au crédit
suisse à genève que de la paris mais je
veux dire par là si vous faites votre si
vous n'avez pas de contrat si vous avez
que des parts de propriété de gens dont
le métier est de créer de la valeur
probablement s'abonnera toujours quelque
chose dans 30 ans donc il faut pas
s'appuyer sur des contrats ce que
j'essaie de dire aux gens c'est que
l'ordre américain actes et s'établit
après 1945 est en train de s'écrouler il
est en train de s'écrouler complètement
sous nos yeux donc bâtir des contrats
sur un ordre juridique acheter des
contrats sur un ordre juridique qui va
disparaître faut être bête mais par
contre d'autres aux propriétés c'est
autre chose c'est quelque chose qui
existe partout qui est vraiment vous
vous achetez des bonnes sociétés ça va
bouger ça va monter ça va baisser ça va
être affreux ne vous les regardez pas et
quand vous prendrez votre retraite vous
aurez ce qu'il vous faut donc encore une
fois la seule façon de s'en sortir c'est
de se libérer de notre dépendance
vis-à-vis de l'état
ne comptez pas sur l'état pour faire
votre retraite c'est vous qui devait la
faire tout seul la parole en l'achetant
désert liquide vous aviez
vous avez
un point de vue sur les crypto et crypto
maudet est ce que ça peut être
une porte de sortie est ce que c'est que
du vent est ce que c'est vachement bien
est-ce que ça permettrait en fait
d'arrêter la production monétaire pour
rien
et puis donc bien plus tôt c'est fini
c'est fini attends je te passe servile
insuline merci beaucoup monseigneur à la
portée de monsieur perdant leur cc 5%
l'année
alors écrite cause lolo ça va être
remplacé un truc très intéressant et
investit moment que je réfléchis je
travaille avec des gens sur les acquis
de la marche a ensuite je vous passe la
parole john oui j moi je je je répète ce
que je dis depuis depuis quinze ans
qu'on pose la question
et je répète toujours la même chose que
ce que les gens n'ont pas l'air de
comprendre quand je construis
il ya des crypto il ya des docks n ya d
qui servent à quelque chose qui
serviront à quelque chose et qui ont
donc une valeur
parce que
elles répondent à une une question une
demande un problème externe
en revanche
il ya tout un tas de saloperies qui ne
vaut rien et on l'a vu d'ailleurs quand
même un peu récemment des trucs qui
était annoncé comme quelque chose qui
était en béton armé qui était décrit
comme un chien et donc qu'ils ont pris
très très cher qui ont peu qu'ils ont
perdu 99 % qui ne veulent plus rien et
c'est donc
voilà je dis comme comme dans tout comme
dans toute innovation technologique il
ya des trucs qui marcheront il ya des
trucs qui sont intéressants il ya des
trucs qu'il faut regarder mais il faut
vraiment les regarder c'est à dire c'est
pas c'est pas juste
allons sur n'importe quoi
on sait qu'il ya des trucs qui sont ce
qu'on appelait des cheats coyne kiki qui
ne servent à qui sont quand même monté
sur des valeurs de 50 milliards de
dollars' pas rien 50 milliards de
dollars sauf que ce truc là c'était deux
mecs bourrés sur le coin d'une table
d'accord qui faisait qu'ils aient une
ligne de code et
qui te lancer sa et kit qui après tu
expliquer alors ça a été curieusement
manipuler parce que évidemment il ya
plein de gens qui ont compris que
c'était beaucoup plus sympathique
d'aller manipuler une une une crypto
parce que comme ça n'est pas un marché
régulé
tu n'as aucun problème ni avec les
autorités de tutelle ni avec quoi que ce
soit donc tu peux la manipuler à loisir
et tu peux faire beaucoup de fric et il
ya des gens qui ont fait beaucoup de
fric dessus en revanche il ya tout un
tas de trucs qui ne servent strictement
à rien qui ne serviront jamais à rien et
qui ruineront tous les gens qui ont cru
à ça et qui sont allés c'est tout mais
comme comme beaucoup de choses cette
hausse est la seule suivante c'est de
lui qu'il ya un truc très intéressant
dans le ring c'est que ça vous permet
non pas d'échapper à l'état parce que ça
personne ne peut y échapper mais
d'échapper au système bancaire c'est à
dire c'est un système de paiement
international sans qu'il y ait aucune
intervention de système bancaire c'est à
dire que vous donner un ordre de
paiement à singapour vous n'avez pas
besoin de passer par un terminal de
paiement etc vous envoyez simplement le
truc et s'est fait dans la seconde donc
c'est insiste c'est une façon de [__]
en 2de d'empêcher la surveillance du
système bancaire poule mais c'est un peu
c'est pas dark pools c'est parfaitement
tonnerre parce que chacune des
transactions dans le crypto est suivie
une par une c'est à dire vous avez une
ligne de transactions s'il ya quelqu'un
derrière le juge d'instruction qui a le
droit de le faire et y en a qui le font
ils remontent toutes les transactions il
voit tout ce qui s'est passé donc en
aucun cas ça ne vous assure la sécurité
mais par contre ça vous assure vous par
exemple
j'ai un compte en hs baissé en compte ce
que j'ai vécu dix ans aux combes chambre
et de l'argent apparaît que j'en ai
besoin chaque fois que j'en vois trois
mille euros
c'est la révolution il téléphone à bercy
monsieur gaffe qui fait rentrer du
poignon c'est sûrement de la drogue etc
donc je veux dire c'est absolument
extraordinaire à quel point mon pognon
dans les banques n'est plus à moi je ne
peux pas le faire payer je peux si
j'essaye de le faire virer et la
première chose qu'ils ont fait quand
j'ai soutenu zemmour là en avant en
acceptant la puissa après que j'avais
soutenu zemmour ils ont fermement contre
nous j'étais depuis 40 ans en france
tous mes grands donc d'un seul coup et
sans compte bancaire cette équipe donc
je peux le dire en face il est vrai
crédit du nord que j'étais depuis 1977
je vais jamais eu un incident ils vous
ont donné cinq ans motifs ou des mots
rien donner du tout là bas tu n'as pas
vous expliquer pour référent pas de
compte
elle peut permettre tous les comptes
sans vous l'a expliqué il faut il faut
vous le sachiez donc je le veux dire par
là c'est que les combien surtout ses
comptes là où il faut avoir trempé leurs
coûts mais ils me les ont donnés mais
les envoyer m'envoyer à chaque megan
n'avait pas de banque pour en trouver
une autre pardon j'ai été ensuite essayé
de mandat à deux banques et m'ont dit ah
non vous êtes maintenant il faisait
d'une personne politiquement dangereuse
donc on ne voit pas de contre ces gens
là donc grosso modo vous rendez pas
compte à quel point vous êtes dépendant
vous
de votre banque
c'est à dire que si vous aviez un conte
bitcoin
vous leur faites le doigt qui sauve
donc c'est ça l'avantagé du bitcoin sais
que ça vous libère du système bancaire
ça vaut libère pas de payer vos impôts
déclarait ce que vous avez déclaré parce
que ça ils peuvent coincer mais ça vous
libère complètement vous vous by pass
vous fait vous vous faites la passe sur
tous les systèmes bancaires vous n'avez
plus rien à [__] c'est pour ça qu'il
ya un problème c'est que je pense qu'à
un moment l'état les probas sifflera la
fin parce qu'on va pas supporter avis tu
pénalise les transactions
comment le faire bassi puisque tu peux
suivre les transactions tu peux les
pénaliser tu peux les pénaliser quand
elles redescendent sur terre mais tant
qu'elle restera tant qu'elle redescende
de là tant qu'elle reste là haut mais on
sait que le bitcoin devenir le système
mondial de deux monnaies 6ème mandela
c'est un système mondial de paiement
mais je pense que ça à cause de sa
possible je pense que l'état à un moment
malheureusement
fera le fera le mais il ya déjà deux
états yab règles seule valeur le seul le
même temps je pense que tous en même
temps le front après je te dis il ya il
ya des choses il ya des choses qui
serviront à quelque chose qui seront
intéressantes il y en a on le sait c'est
qu'il y avait des choses qui se
développe en ce moment qui sont qu'ils
sont
viables est intéressante mais c'est que
c'est exactement comme internet je veux
dire quand internet est arrivé tout le
monde ne jurait que par ça tout le monde
annoncé qu' on allait tout faire par
internet que c'était bon on ne fait
malheureusement tout pour pour servir y
compris envoyer des des trucs de
télévision maintenant tout passe par
internet les tubes tout ça ça passe pas
sauf que tu as des centaines de boîtes
qui sont allés au tapis des centaines de
moines sont allés au tapis non mais je
dis pas que c'est grave jeudi sonne le
monde que la voix chaude et innovation
technologie mécanique et créé aux états
unis il ya six ans constructeurs
automobiles qui sont ils au reste de oui
ça s'appelle la création destructrice et
je dis simplement que sur les milliers
crypto monnaie que tu as aujourd'hui est
de 2,2 d'expérience crypto tu en aura
peut-être quelques unes 10 20 30 jean
sérien qui survivront et le reste qui
ira au tapis et avec des gens qui ont
rêvé de devenir riche rapidement avec ce
truc
taxer la spéculation financière oui
c'est pas bien c'est bien c'est pas bien
ça veut dire quoi ce pécule et celles à
venir en latin ça veut dire réfléchir
donc moi en mon avis on était en train
de taxer la réflexion
il faudrait taxer l'absence de réflexion
dont taxe tobin se sert à rien ça c'est
vrai si vous faites une taxe tobin à
paris toutes les phrases écrites par ils
vont filer à singapour taxe tobin
mondiale mais si on veut dire qu'il ya
un gouvernement mondial et à ce moment
là vous donner le pouvoir à tanis ça
vous fait plaisir on boira attali qui
fait eau ont connaît pas attali on a
essayé de le faire venir mais son
assistante
[Musique]
cet indice est atypique et trompait
surtout c'est pas grave
accident en revanche laisse pour moi la
spéculation inutile par exemple c'est le
trading à haute fréquence hft aucun
intérêt ok ça il faut l'arrêter du jour
l'homme ça n'a aucun intérêt alors là
pour le coup c'est parce qu'ils sont pas
ici la chefferie père frequency trading
c'est que ce que vous mettez devant les
transactions en espérant des cdc d'une
chaleur trading c'est à dire que vous
avez une après une information un petit
peu rapide vous dit il il y a calpers
qui achètent pour 300 millions de
dollars de telles sociétés et vous
déclenchez un ordre juste avant que cal
peur se fasse de façon à essayer de
gratter un huitième de poing un dixième
de point ça ne sert strictement à rien
ça n'a aucun avantage mais c'est là
dessus que goodman & company photo leur
fric c'est c'est du cde du vol à la tire
je comprends pas que ce soit permis
c'est ridicule c'est des algorithmes qui
tourne ma chance il faut être le plus
près possible du mur du new york stock
exchange de façon à ce que le temps soit
le plus bref possible c'est vous dire à
quel point cette dame et ifs il n'y a
aucune information économique là dedans
il ya d'autres choses de bêtes sur les
marchés financiers comme ça que
l'indexation invention de la banque
centrale l'indexation qui est une
stupidité rur puisque la déclaration ce
que vous savez sur vous bâtissez un
indice et puis plus une valeur monde
plus vous devez en avoir c'est à dire
c'est ce qu'on appelle en termes
techniques du momentum buying plus ça
devient gros plus vous en achetez la
base de la finance c'est d'essayer
d'acheter des trucs quand elles sont pas
chères les ventes canadiennes cher et la
saison le contraire c'est plus ça
devient cher plus vous en achetez donc
les systèmes de momentum trading
d'indexation se termine toujours par des
bulles et des krachs
aussi le c'est l'industrialisation de la
gestion en fait c'est à dire que comme
cds des banques de plus en plus énormes
qu'ils se rachètent les unes les autres
et qui deviennent de plus en plus grosse
donc des fonds qui sont de plus en plus
gigantesque avec avec du pognon qui a
été déversée par les banques centrales
et donc en fait qu'est ce qu'elles font
elles font de fond de la mécanique
qu'elles font pas du tout y'a pas
a plus aucune spéculation donc plus
aucune réflexion c'est c'est juste des
machines qui tournent qui achètent elles
sont l sage est en fait tout la même
chose elles ont toutes la même
allocation d'actifs donc il n'ya plus de
il ya plus de gérants ça n'existe plus
aujourd'hui tu as des bécanes qui tourne
et puis qui vont acheter
les cinq plus grosses valeurs de chacun
10 et c'est pour ça que tu vois
d'ailleurs des années où
tu as le standard une course où nasdaq
qui est monté avec cinq valeurs et bien
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que en
fait toutes les gestions mondiale sont
dans ces 5 valeurs alors c'est très
grave c'est c'est que le rôle de la
bourse c'est d'essayer de déterminer
encore une fois la rentabilité marginale
du capital investi or ce n'est pas du
tout ce qu'elle sait jean laffon
c'est-à-dire qui calcule la rentabilité
moyenne du cours de l'action et non pas
du capital en dessous pendant les trois
ou six derniers mois et si ça fait mieux
que le marché je l'achète et donc c'est
un système qui est une forme de
communisme c'est à dire plus c'est gros
plus achète à l'intérêt qui a été
introduit à l'intérêt même du système
capitaliste parce qu'ils sont chargés de
gérer et donc c'est une c'est une c'est
une si tu nous lis intellectuelle c'est
une imbécillité intellectuelle d'avoir
permis la décoration
finir
vous avez forcément des copains encore
dans les salles de marché vous avez
forcément des copains qui travaillent
dans les banques vous avez forcément des
copains copains
forcément des oreilles et des antennes
un peu partout chez jean lion chez les
gens qui commencent à sentir le vent
tourner chez les gens qui ont déjà senti
le vent tourner qu'est ce qu'ils disent
quels sont les états qui se dit est
important c'est que moi quand j'ai
commencé dans ce métier il ya cinquante
ans c'était bourré de gens intelligents
qui était maman comme tout bon et
maintenant si j'ose dire les
administratifs ont pris le contrôle
c'est à dire que c'est plus les ceux qui
prennent les décisions
j'étais au conseil d'une grande société
de réassurance les cinq ou six premières
années c'est dément comme tout parce que
on voyait une op à qui se préparait ses
gains et maintenant 90 % du conseil
quand je suis parti c'était là ce qu'on
appelle la comptoir y est c'est à dire
'est-ce qu'on était en accord avec les
terres qui avait été signé par donc
c'est devenu un métier où les gens sont
merde alors que c'était le métier plus
facilement du monde en cinq étapes
d'être un seul ou comme ayant écouté
j'ai eu je sais pas pourquoi si parce
qu'il faut mais c'est à dire que
maintenant
moi qui avait toute une série
d'originaux dans le métier quand je suis
arrivé j'avais 25 ans et c'était marrant
comme tous les types ils pensaient pas
comme tout le monde et maintenant c'est
devenu une série de petits bobos une
petite petite série quand je suis rentré
dans ce métier j'étais le seul de ma
promotion toulouse on était une centaine
à rentrer dans la finance tout le monde
trouvait que c'était dégueulasse à
financer dans la finance aujourd'hui
tous les enfants de mes amis vont dans
la finance et ils vont faire de leverage
buy out chez pro quoi ils servent à rien
on va rajouter 2 0 et donc je cours je
suis affolé quand je vois tous ces
gamins qui vont aller dans la finance
mais tourné mais qu'est ce que vous
allez y [__]
ceux qui sont encore les pieds sur terre
dès la rentrée rentrer dans l'armée vous
allez avoir du boulot là où il vécut ce
qui se dit libre de pouvoir chez chez
les initiés
ça sent ça sent le ride d'offres ça sent
le sapin ça sent le sapin les clous plus
le ripolin où ça sent le sapin et ça
part et ça sent il
des gens ont peur les gens qui ont une
activité son actif qui ont dès qu'ils
ont des sociétés mais
enfin regarde regarde le le gars qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure en bas là au bar en
bar parce que tous les deux vous êtes
des vrais stars non mais au bar en bas
tu as tu as des gens qui sont nés lol
patron du bar et qui te dit qu'ils te
dis mais on
ne sait plus quoi faire je sais plus
quoi faire je n'arrive plus à recruter
j'arrive plus ces gens là d'accord mais
je parle de ceux qui commencent à sentir
à se placer investir en norvège où tout
le monde le sent tout le monde le sens
du gars qui
qui qui qui a une grosse boîte qui qui
tourne qu'il ya de l'argent qui
jusque jusque patrons aux petits patrons
qui qui sont dans la même problématique
qui disent on comprend pas où on va on
est géré par départ départ départ des
débiles et et des débiles que l'on force
gérer de façon débile moi j'ai entendu
pas j'étais j'ai écouté une très grosse
famille française qu'il ya des biens
immense et c'est d'une holding familiale
qui est gérée en suisse compterait bien
et encore des patriots a encore des
patriotes mais ça c'est mes yeux ça fait
un petit moment qu'ils sont là donc mais
ça se veut dire c'est c'est très utile
je veux dire il ya aucune raison de se
faire massacrer je veux dire le sait que
vous non mémorisant depot center il ya
un arrêt de la cour suprême des
etats-unis qui lie le devoir le devoir
de tout citoyen c'est de payer le moins
d'impôt possible légalement le devoir
parce que donner de l'argent à l'état
qui vont faire n'importe quoi c'est un
crime
donc arrêter de dire que les gars qui
j'ai alors un plan convenablement ce
sont des [__] la réalité c'est que ce
qui les empêche de gérer leur argent
qu'on pour le moment sont des [__]
parce que loïs à faire quoi avec donc
encore une fois c'est des lions vue de
ce point de vue c'est que c'est
l'histoire des talents dans les
évangiles vous avez le gars lui donne
quatre cale en 1h24 de talent et laurent
2 et celui qui dentaire
celui là est bien c'est celui-là qui
vendent en faire dans ce tri essayer de
vous dire c'est que ceux qui ont la
capacité de créer des talents il faut
bien leur [__] la paix parce que si
vous donnez tout le pognon à celui qui
l'enterrent on va tous crever et c'est
ce que fait la france depuis de 40,1 de
filer tout le pognon celui qui enterre
le talent à monsieur mélenchon
c'est ça qu'on est en droit et avec les
meilleures intentions du monde ces cons
là ils ont gagné d'argent c'est des
ordures regardez ils ont doublé leur
fric c'est une autre mais ce qui est une
honte c'est d'avoir un capital et pas le
dopage vous développez vous vous rendez
pas compte vous pensé gagner de l'argent
c'est mal mais si c'était pas si c'était
tellement mal essayé de le faire l'impôt
sur les successions vous en pensez quoi
mais moi je préfère que ça il ya les
riquet cas l'état qui a rien fait pour
le gagner moi il me semble qu'il vaut
beaucoup mieux laisser le pognon à l'eau
secteur privé au secteur public
redistribution c'est pas tout mais pas
du tout la redistribution il est normal
qu'il y ait des gens qu'on aime les ceux
qui sont pas mais je vais pas filer du
pognon au jeune gitan aide à des gens
qui n'ont jamais rien foutu de toute
leur vie vous vous faites rigoler moi
j'ai été un sportif toute ma vie je
rugby joué au tennis quelle position mon
rugby j'étais troisième ligne au tennis
jettent état de grande série donc
j'étais pas mal j'étais à la limite du
professionnalisme mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que vous apprenez à
gagner le coeur je gagnais pas un match
de tennis le jeudi ou le vendredi on
payait plus l'hôtel on payait plus à
bouffer ben je vais aller dormir sur la
plage je bouffais pas
j'avais pas de redistribution des prix
vous faites rigoler
c'est encore une fois cette espèce de
truc de dire on a le droit celui qui ne
fût ce que disait milton friedman 1 il
avait un truc qui était génial il disait
alors il ya quatre façons de dépenser
d'argent vous gagnez de l'argent et vous
le dépenser pour vous en général c'est
bien dépensé vous savez s'il vous plaît
vous gagnez de l'argent et vous le
dépenser par exemple pour votre femme
vous l'achetez un bouquet de fleurs vont
rentrer à la maison a dit qu'est ce que
tu as fait comme conneries encore avec
le bouquet de favoriser qu'est-ce que tu
dois te faire pardonner quoi tu te tais
toi que c'est pas gagner à tous les
coups ce coup là oui je pars c'est pas
le cas dans mon cas mais je veux dire c
appuyez ensuite y'a quelqu'un qui gagne
qui gagnent de l'argent et que vous le
donne à vous
l'héritage bon bah vous le dépenser à
peu près complètement mais si c'est
quelqu'un qui vienne dollar qui n'a pas
gagné d'argent et qui prend de l'argent
à quelqu'un d'autre pour le donner un
troisième alors ça c'est du grand
n'importe quoi c'est toujours la ruine
ça ne marche jamais et c'est l'état
c'est le socialisme donc si vous voulez
vous demandé aux socialistes de piquer
du pognon à ceux qui seront capables de
faire quelque chose pour le dos des
dégâts qui ont feront rien et en la
regardant 90% au milieu pour faire des
fonctionnaires qui serviront à rien
qu'ils créeront aucune valeur mais vous
rendez pas compte de ce que vous dites
c'est phénoménal que des conneries alors
comment on fait pour investir sur le
long terme faut faire des plans
thermonucléaire comment on fait pour
faire de la planification s'ils ont
connu des financements privés et de gaza
des gens qui bien que tous les fonds de
pension donc j'avance je vous donnais
des droits aucun fait mention au fonds
de pension canadien qui vient d'investir
en france sur notre oreille a rien de
concret ça il ya un truc très souvent
contre vous préférez que sur le logo
français quelle france et qui décrit
faire n'importe quoi avec nick regardez
ce qu'ils ont fait avec edf regarde ce
que regarde regarde un
tu prends le cas d'un dingue ariel c'est
facile c'est facile si faisait pas ça
c'était la révolution dans les rues
c'est facile de mensah d obliger à
vendre leur père a créé une espèce de
concurrence faux ce qui a été demandé
par l'europe alors que sega produit j'ai
rien on faisait produire de
l'électricité à edf ce qui avait été
payée par des impôts des français et on
la fera le forcer l'edf à la vendre à
des gens qui l'avaient ensuite au public
en faisant croire que c'était à eux
qu'il avait construit qu'il avait
produit mais à berlin produit du tout
c'était juste du capitalisme de
connivence mais il y avait des gars qui
avaient payé les payer l'élection de
macron et qu'il fallait bien leur
envoyer quelques saucisses de la
supputation ou sinon bon chez paul le
sens de maquereaux à supputer sur votre
soutien
ya quelque chose que tu peux faire si tu
veux faire cela at il du concept d'
impôt négatif de milton friedman c'est
très mal à ça je peux l'expliquer c'est
extraordinaire moment là
vous souhaitez hockey
concept vous avez un gars mettons que le
smic soit 12 cents les uns ils étaient
200 malheureusement le gave où
l'embauché il vous produit au mieux 6
ans de valeur
donc vous allez pas l'embaucher
alors ce que les méthodes friedman si
vous l'embauché vous le payez six ans
qui produit comme valeur
vous le former et l'étain fou paye la
différence entre 600 et 2 cents le
principe de l'apprenti ou du style c'est
çà la preuve déjà germé l'état paie la
différence entre ce qui vous coûte ainsi
qu'il est a
cédé t'annoncer les taxes et les impôts
ça sert à quelque chose je n'en avais
jamais dit que l'état est absolument
nécessaire c'est un mal nécessaire
n'oubliez pas les temps dans le son rôle
régalien c'est absolument indispensable
parce que il a aussi volé une société
sans réserve vous allez en sicile et ça
marche pas terrible hein il n'y a pas de
droit de propriété rien donc je suis
vous voulez un principe ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on n'est pas un état
qui capture les à la richesse sans la
mariée a aucune raison de gueuler
mais ça c'est autre chose mais donc
l'impôt négatif l'état paie la
différence entre des six ans et dix ans
puis d'année prochaine le gaffer vaut à
peu près 900 tant qu'il peut plus de 300
l'état puis ensuite le niveau douceur
l'état cesse de pipi ou encore govou
c'est sens il n'est pas douce si le type
le 21 10 ans à ce moment là c'est lui
qui se bat pour aller dans le marché se
faire payer 16 cents donc c'est une
façon d'amener les gens qui n'ont pas la
rentabilité du cap et de leur travail
suffisante de les amener à un endroit et
si le type mal et n'est pas capable de
le reste à 6 ans et mais au moins il et
pas déshonoré parce qu'il travaille pas
il est là il touche seydoux sens et il
fait un boulot il va au bureau il
rencontre des gens il va lui rencontre
des gens donc c'est une façon de faire
rentrer les gens sans cette espèce de
les idées que milton friedman le chèque
éducation c'est absolument générale la
peau négatif c'est absolument génial n'y
a pas une bonne par exemple le bitcoin
c'est une idée de 8 en prime les gens ne
savent pas mais
j'aimerais bien voir un peu c'est tout
ce voisin
il est fâché non pas fâchés mais sans
doute il fâché je me suis posé la
question tout à l'heure de 2 comment
investir et je te réponde et le privé il
ya des choses par exemple là pour le
coup
tu verrais tu verras une autre façon de
2,2 financés
le gars qui vend son entreprise ou même
cette histoire d'héritage
tu sais ce que tu fais tu dis voilà si
vous réinvestissez dans une entreprise
mais vraiment une entreprise par pas des
fonds à la con ex tard si vous
investissez dans une entreprise un à ce
moment là le temps de votre de votre
plus value eh bien vous ne payez pas de
plus value vous investissez dans cette
entreprise de succession et de et les
droits de succession pareil c'est à dire
que vous touchez une succession je dis
n'importe quoi d'un million euros
si pendant les trois ou quatre ou cinq
prochaines années vous réinvestissent et
500 mille balles dans une entreprise
pour qu elle pour qu'elle puisse
investir ou pour que l puisse financer
son besoin en fonds de roulement à ce
moment là vous ne payez pas d'impôts
et à ce moment là tu sera beaucoup plus
productif ça sera beaucoup plus
intéressant que
que de filer ça à l'état qui lui va
investir mais comme il sait pas investir
parce qu'il ya quand même une bande de
branquignols là dedans qui est assez
extraordinaire et bien à ce moment là tu
perds sur sur le sur ce que tu as donné
à l'état et qui est mal hein esti ou pas
du tout investi qui sert à payer les
dépenses courantes et bien tu n'as
absolument aucun retour la torre quelque
chose d'intéressant et là il ya des
millions il ya des millions chaque année
il ya des gens qui vendent leurs
entreprises qui font des plus values etc
tu pourrais les réinvestir ces plus
values au lieu de payer des impôts
avec l'asie
village de l'âge attention attention le
micro écran par terre je vais m'en
occuper non impeccable charles tu sais
tu te sens tu chantes
non je déconne pas tu sais où c'est
charles oui en tout cas on va en
profiter pour pouvoir parler de lévis
c'était en train de dire quoi donc notre
à glace sur l'investissement c'est à
dire que on sait très bien que
l'investissement de l'état c'est c'est
pas de l'investissement c'est du leu leu
l'état ses dépenses la grande majorité
de ces dépenses c'est payer les charges
courantes dont il n'y a pas
d'investissement pour toi les plus gros
risques de cette année et des cinq
prochaines années c'est quoi c'est
l'écroulement c'est ce qu'on me dit
écroulement de la monnaie parce que je
te dis ils ne peuvent plus revenir en
arrière donc tadla comme aujourd'hui
tadla comme te disant exactement comme
fin 2018 si tu veux tu avais pauwels qui
aux états unis avait dit ah bah on va
arrêter les y est les curieux on va
monter les taux on peut supporter trois
ennemis tôt parce que on a de la
croissance etc deux mois plus tard -20 à
-25% sur le stand à rennes pour cent et
puis on s'aperçoit que l'économie
commencé à
aller vers le bas et la panique et ah
bah non excusez-nous enfin bon c'est mal
on s'est mal compris et c'est je
recommence les quantitative easing et je
baisse les taux et c'est là qu'on est
passé en effet on avait atteint 3 c'est
là qu'on est passé de 3 à 0 0 70 0,81
sur le 10 ans avec donc il se passera
exactement la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui ils font les marioles
alors que tu as une récession était à -1
et demi sur le pib c'est pas rien
d'accord sur le premier trimestre et tu
penses bien qu'avec ce qui se passe sur
la hausse des ddd des prix
sur le deuxième trimestre va pas être
meilleur que le premier au contraire il
va être bien pire que le premier donc ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on sera
officiellement en récession qu'est ce
qui va se passer tu crois qu'ils vont
continuer à monter les taux d'intérêt
pendant la récession non bien sûr que
non ils vont les rebaisser et même s'ils
savent très bien qu'au final ils vont
générer encore une dépréciation de la
monnaie et donc encore plus d'inflation
sans faute il considère qu' il considère
que de toute façon cette inflation
perdre leur permettra de détruire en
fait la dette donc ils sont ravis je te
renvoie charles
donc charles on était en train de poser
la question les plus gros risques cette
année et pour les cinq prochaines années
c'est quoi
ça va bien ça va beaucoup mais j'aurais
pu faire réfléchir à nouveau vous savez
ce que vous rigolez mais c'est le bo
verrez quand vous dirait mon âge aura
pas autant ben y'a que des jeunes ici de
fo se redresser oui il faudrait c'est
bon
je vais vous dire ce qu'elle est le
risque
à mon avis vous vous endormez en 1780 5
vous vous réveillez en 1820 vous
comprenez rien
le monde a changé au delà tout ce qui
était possible vous endormez en
1895 vous vous réveillez en 10 920 on
comprenait rien
vous vous endormez en 2000 en 1995 année
aurait vers 2020 me comprenez rien
celui-ci a disparu
la chine est devenue la première
puissance mondiale bref je comprenais
rien la durée de vie des institutions
humaines c'est à peu près 70 ans
et on est en train d'arriver à la fin
d'un cycle
il ya quelque chose qui est derrière et
moi je crois que ce qui va s'écrouler
c'est la social démocratie européenne
c'était une fausse idée d le débat
est donc toute cette espèce de
construction aujourd'hui par exemple
entre le pib de la france et un pour
cent du pib mondial et les dépenses
d'une sociale de la france et 9% des
dépenses sociales mondiale
ça n'est pas possible
donc ce que vous allez avoir c'est assez
simple c'est que vous allez avoir un
effondrement de toutes les espèces de
faux structures qu'on nous a mis depuis
quarante cinq
couples qui est beaucoup de gens qui
vivent grâce à ça
et il y avait plein de gens qui vivaient
grâce à la royauté plein de gens qui
vivaient dans l' empire russe ou d'un
leurre pirates shaker l' empire
austro-hongrois etc je n'ai pas dit que
c'était bien
il faut encore failli en faire une
différence entre ce que vous souhaitez
et ce qui va arriver
ce que je dis aux jeunes on sait il va y
avoir une prime extra ordinaire à la
flexibilité dans les années qui viennent
comme
2895 de
1920 si vous restez dans le même coin
vous étiez mal paraît donc les
structures que vous croyez pérenne ne le
sont pas elles vont disparaître et ces
structures c'est peut-être la commission
européenne sait pas ce que c'est mais de
regarder déjà l'angleterre a quitté
l'europe si jamais un bon signe quand
l'angleterre se barde quelque chose en
général c'est que le futur et pas
tellement bon
donc j'essaye simplement de vous dire
si vous croyez qu'elle quelque chose de
certain vous vous trompez
donc le carton du mur le long terme ans
est pas certain
si c'est ça se produira mais je ne sais
pas quelles en seront les conséquences
et les conséquences sont elles pas la
même pour l'état lié pour la france pour
l'allemagne et pour l'angleterre et
c'est à chacun des pays réagira avec sa
sauce au rejet n'est propre question de
hassan
si on doit uniquement misé sur le
secteur privé comment les services
essentiels seront il assuré dans les
autres rues à l'isoler et marginalisés
ou g le secteur privé gagnera de
l'argent si le secteur privé gagne de
l'argent et s'il est si les gens qui
sont chargés de le redistribuer ne se
sert pas au passage de 90% ça ira
beaucoup bien que ce problème c'est pas
des tu as ma soeur à un petit à petit et
qu'elle était moche populi un ouais les
traits pauline obama sur une petit
teckel car elle amène chez le
vétérinaire ses 150 euros
aussi chili a fait une petite opération
à faire cent cinquante 150 au mythique
jeu pascal à la petite bête mais enfin
il ya ça lui a coûté sa par contre quand
vous allez chez le docteur
chez moi dans la région d'avignon il
touche 27 euros
donc tant qu'on perd à l'essai de
vétérinaires 150 euros pour ce que peut
noter qu'elle est 27 euros pour
s'occuper de moi il y aura pas beaucoup
de docteurs m'avaient campagne en
question question de cbi pour charles
gave
quid du soutien milton freeman à des
dictateurs d'extrêmement le chili de
pinochet pour garantir une
transformation de l'état de façon non
démocratique et imposer le libéralisme
après la victoire du socialisme c'est
bien ça pour les peuples c'est bien les
chars fasciste et l'économie libérale
quoi qu'il en coûte pas interrogations à
ce jeune garçon ne sait rien comme des
comme disait j'avais un jour vu une
interview d'un type on intervient
inquiéter la science pour le poser des
questions sur tocqueville issam est rien
et il y avait raymond aron qui écoute et
qui a dit bien entendu ce jeune homme ne
sait rien donc je vais vous expliquer
alors
l'université de santiago avait un accord
avec l'université de chicago depuis 1928
où il y avait des échanges de
professeurs et ça se passait très bien
monsieur allende qui avait fait 35% des
voix a été élu dans une espèce
d'élections triangulaires qui était une
particularité de là donc c'est un point
très bref dans l'espace de 3 4 ans
l'économie était par terre un peu comme
l'économie vénézuélienne aujourd'hui il
y avait les infâmes kita mais bref il ya
eu un coup d'état ce coup d'état
monsieur amenait monsieur alliant des
mains de monsieur pinault chez monsieur
pinault chez après pouvoir déclare me
lis moi sont les etats unis sans doute
message les états unis en amérique
latine ils sont assez
actifs mais en même temps si vous voulez
enfin bref on parvenir suscitant parce
que c'est trop compliqué je peux avoir à
raconter mais c'est pas la peine d'un
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est que
monsieur pinault c est donc à simplement
est revenu à des prix de marché il a
arrêté le blocage des prix donc il a
fait une politique libérale très dur en
se vidant venu à la réalité économique
au prix de marché
l'économie chilienne est aller beaucoup
mieux
sur la période la fait beaucoup mieux
depuis que toutes les autres économies
en amérique latine après les sanctions
américaines
après 20 minutes fois que monsieur
pinault chez après le pouvoir il a
rétabli les faits ce qui s'est passé
c'est que
dans le cadre de l'échangé entre chicago
et en 1924 fait 228 et de santiago
mais d'entraînement est venu faire une
une conférence à l'université de chicago
je veux rien avoir à cacher pinochet a
demandé à le voir comme l'avait demandé
mao que vous l'avez demandé tout le
monde lui aux méthodes friedman c'est
tellement une vedette incroyable donc
comme l'avait demandé le gouvernement
français shirakawa 6000 tonnes friedman
et cnra et donc voilà c'est il a une été
reçus et
le plan qui avait été mis en oeuvre par
un des brothers de l'université de
santiago qui s'appuyait sur le libre
marché qui amerrir l'avoir de a été
acceptée quelques années après pinochet
fait un référendum pour demander si tu
es resté aussi départir il a perdu il
est parti il n'y a pas eu de référendum
à cuba il a pas eu de référendum à
venezuela il n'y a pas eu de référendum
donc si vous voulez j'aimerais bien que
ce jeune garçon
se donne la peine de lire milton
friedman aussi curieux que cela paraisse
était un homme de gauche vous habitez
dans le désert d'atacama
moi j'étais une fois au chili toujours
déjà enterré dans le désert d'atacama
non bon ça veut le gérant très
légèrement mais il y en a beaucoup plus
à cuba ou venezuela qui en a eu jamais
au chili je sais pas je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la chose mais
j'avais l'amérique latine n'a jamais été
de me rendre sympathique ainsi si ces
films on s'est regardés l'amérique
latine c'est quand même extraordinaire
vous avec un pays comme l'argentine qui
était le deuxième niveau de vie du monde
qui est maintenant au niveau 1 niveau de
développement complètement parce qu'ils
sont tous complètement crétin pourquoi
vous à quoi pourquoi il s'est passé 5 la
cantine parce qu'ils ont parce qu'ils
auraient eu une espèce de type qui
s'appelait
comment il s'appelle général
péroniste non permanents et c'était
c'était la crétinerie total com c'était
la corruption c'est est ce que vous
voulez puis ensuite vous avez le
venezuela qui était là aussi le niveau
de vie plus élevé de l'amérique latine
pendant très longtemps maintenant qui
est le pays officiellement le plus
pauvre
de l'amérique latine donc et tout ça
c'est cuba qui était le niveau des deux
plus élevé des caraïbes qui est
maintenant le plus pauvre de toutes les
caraïbes donc si vous voulez danser
troisième zone vous avez eu des
pratiques socialiste donc il faut quand
même pas mettre sur le dos du
capitalisme quand c'est c'est comme si
on disait si vous voulez que l'union
soviétique a échoué à cause du
libéralisme
faut pas déconner quoi il ya des miens
mais à un moment il faut regarder la
réalité en face la guerre froide si ça
vous savez ça a été un peu cueilli à
froid
en quoi celle de la guerre froide pour
faire une mue l'union soviétique
qu'est-ce qui se veut avoir les mains
qu'ils étaient là bas au fin fond de
l'argentine sous les mots j'étais en
argentine vous allez en argentine vous
des parcs l aéroport et vous avez des
énormes affiches partout sur le musée de
la dette la dette qui sera encore encore
et qui n'ont jamais repayer ils en sont
fiers
ils sont fiers vous avez le musée de la
dette
c'est quand même étonnant des gens qui
se glorifie d'avoir emprunté de l'argent
la communauté nationale et de l'avoir
jamais repayer
c'est quand même étrange qu'elle tousse
et de cette v2 pays bas je manquerais
probablement un taux très supérieur s'il
avait été gérée convaincant c'est aussi
la veille c'est quoi les fonds vautours
c'est quoi vous touche il faut vautours
c'est simplement quand l'argentine fait
faillite la dette tombe à 2 cents du
dollar et il ya des types qui arrivent
et qui achète la dette à 200 c qui
essayent de la revendre à 400 salles
argentine d apple ça faut autour c'est à
dire c'est des gars qui sait gagner
d'argent sur une dette sur lequel tout
le monde a perdu
olivier question internet free telecom
qui sort de la bourse et qui conquis
l'europe
d'accord n'a jamais dit que la bourse
était sur gilles avait des cash-flows
positifs algérien c'est un mouvement de
cet idéal c'est ce point je disais tout
à l'heure tu avais une marche et à plus
de bourses aujourd'hui c'est un viser un
casino sanaa ça n'a plus rien à voir
avec la bourse c'est pas là pour
financer des entreprises la bourse
aujourd'hui tu quand tu quand tu as des
du trading à haute fréquence etc ça sert
à quoi ça sert pas à financer une
entreprise tout faire tondre oui non
mais aujourd'hui ça ça ne sert qu'à ça
la bourse ça sert pas autre chose donc
qui est d'aider des boîtes qui se retire
de la bourse vu comme c'est aujourd'hui
gérée tu as vu il ya il ya eu quand même
ce qu'on appelle des flash krach
pourquoi les flash krach parce que tout
simplement tu as des algorithmes qui
gère tout ça avec du trading à haute
fréquence et que tout d'un coup sûr un
mot sur un truc pouf
sur un gars qui met qui met un zéro de
plus tu vois pas ce que offre et puis ça
passe et tu as des milliards sont
déversés à ce moment là tu as des gens
qui comme beaucoup d'argent tu fais du
moins 20 la seconde d'après tes revenus
au même niveau si c'est ça si tu veux
c'est devenu sa la bourse que y ait des
entreprises qui se retire de la bourse
et qu'ils aillent
vivent de leurs propres ailes sans sans
bourse ça me paraît très bien souvent tu
sais ça ça ne flatte que l'ego du du
président de pouvoir envoyer des ballons
à la bourse de new york mais finalement
ça leur coûte souvent beaucoup plus cher
que que que ça leur rapporte question
pour chaque que pense-t-il de la
recherche publique et qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent de l'économie sociale
responsable et qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
du conseil national de la résistance
le contenu social responsable je connais
pas une seule une seule entreprise qui
soit pas social responsable présent très
simple c'est qu'ils vous n'êtes ni
social et responsable vous fait faillite
donc les entreprises sont ni sociale ni
responsable elles font faillite parce
que les doyens du mal à trouver des
employés et puis ensuite à leurs clients
les emplois donc moi la seule chose que
j'ai remarqué c'est que sur les
énergéticiens et pas de problème les
torchères en afrique c'est pas de
problème les marées noires et pas de
problème
c'est variable et prenez un travesti si
tout va bien aussi j'ai pas dit ça mais
je sais par exemple il y avait plus de
malaria en afrique et maintenant elle
est revenue il ya des tas de gens et des
millions de morts qui est des millions
de gens qui meurent de la malaria bon on
mettait un truc s'appelle flytox donc on
était enfin partout où j'allais y avait
des facteurs qui entraînent aussi des ti
vous savez que la dtcc flytox il y avait
plus de malaria l'afrique elle est
revenue il ya des millions de morts bon
ben je suis content pour les moustiques
mais
parfois il ya des combats qui sont
menées qui sont des combats qui me
paraît pas qui me paraissent pas
particulièrement intéressant quand je
serai pas
et encore une fois c'est dans le cadre
des loirs mois ci
le le propre il peut pas y avoir de
crime s'il n'y a pas de loi c'est un
début plus vieux principe juridique ni
la crds iman signer les jo s'il n'ya pas
de loi n'y a pas de crime donc imaginer
que des gars et
ont ployé du ddt en afrique il ya 50 ans
espère empêcher le
malaria cette époque bon c'est peut-être
un crime rétrospectivement c'était un
crime parce que peut-être ça donnait des
maladies aux bêtes j'en sais rien mais à
l'époque ça n'en était pas donc si vous
dites vous si vous rentrez dans le
système du principe de précaution de
chirac
on va tous mourir d'ennui il se battra
jamais rien tout sera interdite
d'aspirine sera interdite parce que donc
il faut arrêter de juger les événements
d'aujourd'hui en fonction de ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui qu'ils sont passés il
ya cent ans vous voulez utiliser toutes
les drogués un charles
oui
moi je suis tout à fait partisan de la
légalisation de la recherche publique et
sert
c'est malheureusement très souvent un
affichage
c'est de la com d'ailleurs tu as plein
de boîtes qui vont pour rentrer
justement banc des fonds qui sont serre
qui vont te créer une division sr et
crié sur tous les toits que il a plus
blanc que blanc je pense pas me tromper
orpea était pas bon alors fin de
l'histoire quoi un
européen des chiffres européens
sont les mieux assainies rassure toi le
truc
c'est qu'il ya un vrai problème si vous
voulez c'est que normalement enfin je
sais pas les vieux
il se passe quelque chose de curieux
dans nos pays gelé très bien vu au
moment de déco vite
c'est que dans le temps les vieux
il mourrait à la maison entourée de
l'affection des leurs
maintenant je sais pas ce qui se passe
mais
on les envoie mourir dans des trucs là
bas il se passe quelque chose dans notre
civilisation qui est pas très
sympathique ni pour les vieux ni pour
les jeunes donc s'il essaie de dire aux
gens c'est dit une cécité qui regardez
par exemple ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis qui me tracasse énormément
c'est tous ses singles et de 18 19 ans
20 ans tous ces mecs qui arrivent qui
prennent des flingues et qui vont
descendre des enfants dans une école
ça se produisait pas il ya 30 ou 40 ans
qu'est ce qu'on a fait aux jeunes
garçons qu'est ce qui arrive pourquoi
les mecs de 20 18 20 ans sont ils
maintenant en train de descendre des
gens dans des écoles qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est ce qui se passe dans leur tête
pourquoi il ya 30 ou 40 ans il n'y avait
jamais un gars qu'elle détient dans une
école ses 40 ans ça existait pas donc
qu'est ce qui se passe pour qu'on laisse
nos vieux crevé et de l'autre côté que
les jeunes deviennent des fous assassin
qu'ils achètent des trucs pour des
restructurations mais je sais pas ce que
c'est mais il ya quelque chose qui veut
dire qu'on est méchamment malades dans
ma tête je pense que c'est moi c'est ça
qui m'a dit à la blague je répondais
juste sur charles un petit coup
de la résistance
ceci dit non c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer maintenant qui est
intéressant le ce qui s'est passé le
lendemain de la guerre de 40 on s'en
fout un peu
le ciss aussi intéressant c'est que
c'est que en effet c'est une fin de
civilisation c'est même pas une crise
économique qu'on est plus là voilà il ya
quelque chose aujourd'hui le sait les
autres régions le walk l'hommage à tous
à ccc une fin de civilisation il ya
quelque chose qui est pas normal je veux
dire ce que tu disais charles venu saisi
jeudi à partir du moment où on offre
aussi aux gens qui regardent la
socialisation comme
projets pour le futur l'euthanasie pour
les vieux parce qu'il faut bien qu'ils
plutôt que d'aller au rhdp alors ils
seront maltraités au moins qu'on les tue
sa quasi cécité en grande souffrance qui
a pu de migrer vers vous aimez moi tout
ça c'est du groupe hip hop parce que
j'avais un peu le père d'une de mes
amies en suède qui souffrent énormément
qui disait tu es assez demande à sa
fille de le tuer et la fille a dit
écoute papa j'ai mis une petite pilule
dans sa table de nuit si tu veux tu
l'apprends débat il n'a jamais pris
donc le goût de la grande souffrance
c'est surtout parce qu'un héritage a
touché 1 faut pas déconner donc cessé
pour se débarrasser des vieux parce que
maintenant les héritages et vont plus au
pain aux enfants ils vont aux
petits-enfants voire aux arrières
petits-enfants donc ça c'est pas
possible donc il faut les tuer tout de
suite bon ben l'appartement n'en parlons
pas c'est pas un aveu donc grosso modo
on offre comme vision dans le futur
l'avortement l'euthanasie et le
téléphone apple
ça me paraît pas un projet de vie
particulièrement bouleversant oui tu
veux rebondir sur l'euthanasie
avortement si de suite parce qu'il est
là où on est à fond mais on est à fond
c'est ce que je dis enfin deux enfin
d'organisation regarde regarde ce qui se
passe un petit peu partout dans le monde
on glisse vers quelque chose qui qui
au-delà bien au delà de
de la chute du cac40 ou dont tout le
monde se fout il suffit de pas avoir de
cac 40 et c'est tranquille dans la vie
et est
même un écroulement économique
aujourd'hui tu es dans quelque chose qui
qui va bien au delà un espèce de modèles
qu'on essaie de nous imposer qui est un
modèle soviétique
c'est à dire regarde le programme de
mélenchon c'est intéressant à ce niveau
là et puis et puis ce qui a été
d'ailleurs initié par macro
donc tu es en train de se lier teasé
l'économie qui est en train on te parle
de revenu universel on te parle d'eux on
est en train de problème ah oui ça pose
un gros problème
cela pose un gros problème parce que
parce que le revenu universel si tu veux
c'est c'est la porte ouverte à un
contrôle totale par l'état qui te dira
au bout d'un moment j'écoute mon p'tit
vieux situe si tu n'es pas vacciner
trois fois par mois si tu n'es pas si tu
ne fais pas ce que je te dis tu n'as pas
prévenu tu dépends de l'état mais au
final tu as bien retiens ça ne l'était
en italien quelqu'un devait s'y loger on
t'a bien quelqu'un qu'il fait ce pognon
avant de le redistribuer avant de le
donner à tout le monde avant que
simplement le fait que tu laisses tu
reçois de l'argent qui le fait qu'ils le
fait cet art auquel droit lui prends ton
de quel droit lui prends ton pourra
pourquoi doit-on prendre quelque chose
qui a donné le droit monsieur mélenchon
de décider que personne ne doit avoir
plus 2 j'ai beaucoup moins 2 millions
j'en sais rien quel est le droit
philosophie quelle est la philosophie
derrière chaque mesure prise par
mélenchon il ya une contrainte contre la
liberté individuelle c'est toujours ça
la base du social ifss et de diminuer la
liberté individuelle pour donner du
pouvoir aux types qui est le chef donc
encore une fois on a cette espèce de
truc c'est ce que disait bastia qui
était dans les commissions variabiliser
seigneur
protégez moi de ceux qui veulent m'en
viens pas mon bien au titre de la
fortune mais qu'ils veulent mais qui
veulent que je sois plus heureux ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'elle mais foutez
la paix aux gens la base de notre
société chrétienne c'est
l'individu il n'y aura jamais un autre
charles garde dans l'histoire le moment
je suis un ami du totalement unique
comme l'a été tous les hommes depuis le
début des temps et je dois avoir un
projet unique et c'est à moi de le
trouver s'il n'y a pas de projet
collectif ces espèces d'horreur
collective que nous proposons mélenchon
ça me rend si j'appelle gens ils en
changent dudit ouvrir des mains de
charles diers et qui vous acceptez
évidemment j'aurais fait si
tu leur dis
non non c'est simplement parce que si
mes et est en plus et en plus je te lis
sais c'est pas que mélenchon macron à
fait la même chose tout ce qu'a dit le
type de du davos comme ils s'appellent
le phare sont comme ça mais il a dit il
faut qu'on arrive à un monde il y aura
l'individu et de gouvernement mondial et
rien entre et vous rendez compte que ça
veut dire plus de familles plus de club
de foot plus d'églises plus d'endroits
où on se retrouve entre copains on va
boire un coup l'individu et son maître
le gouvernement mondial mais c'est
abominable
ces listes étaient mauvaises
interprétations vous avez eu à benoît il
l'a dit lui a dû à davos le la semaine
dernière c'est quand même étonnant je le
veux dire par là c'est que ces gars là
ils ont une espèce d'idée de l'homme qui
est interchangeable
question olivier delamarche la chine et
sa puissance plus et plus qui émergentes
étaient bien peu abordé ce soir le
dollar monnaie internationale est-il en
danger
immédiat à la faveur d'un rapprochement
stratégique russie chine conséquences
possibles pour l'intérêt formuler
correctement les questions des enfants
écoute moi j'ai écrit là-dessus
déjà cinq ans je crois que charles aussi
a écrit là-dessus le les chinois sont en
train de
2,2
d'indexer leur monnaie et de sueur sur
l'or des réserves qu'ils ont constituée
qui sont
beaucoup plus importantes que ce qui que
ce qu'ils racontent
un moment on a évalué le stock le stock
d'or de la chine mais ça fait déjà deux
trois ans à autour de 20 mille tonnes
donc on est très très loin de moi c'est
tout simplement de faire des quelques
calculs de regarder ce que ce qu'ils
produisent de regarder ce qui passe par
hong kong ce qui passe par différents
différentes fonderie en suisse puissent
qui refonde tu sais absolument tout ce
qu'ils achètent donc dès qu'ils achètent
un lingot ou dès qu'ils achètent des
lingots un petit peu partout ils les
refontes ils les font passer par de deux
fonderies suisses ils les refonde et les
renvoie chez eux donc entre ce qui est
déclarait ce qui est officieux et
officiels
on pense qu' il serait plus proche de 20
mille tonnes que que des 3000 ou 3500
chez plus qu il déclare alors après si
tu veux c'est des estimations sanaa ça
n'a pas valeur de de vérité absolue et
de graver dans le marbre mais on pense
que c'est à peu près c'est cesser ces
montants là sachant que il déclare un
certain nombre de deux
d'achat tout au long des années qu'a
priori si tu veux je pense pas que ce
soit que pour faire des boucles
d'oreilles tu vois donc y en a quand
même une bonne partie qui atterrit à la
banque centrale et que donc on peut
estimer en effet que leur lot réserves
sont beaucoup plus importantes que ça
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
il créé un standard ça ils ont fait des
essais de pétrole avec les russes pour
payer en guyane en yuan convertible en
or donc cette avait un contrat sur le
pétrole qui étaient pour pour payer
cette ce pétrole on or en yuan
convertible en a donc ils ont fait des
essais moi je pense que
ils vont en effet aller vers ça et que
ce qui se passe notamment en russie
aujourd'hui va pousser et accélérait
encore les choses et qui vont sortir une
monnaie qui sera une monnaie convertible
est basé sur l'or et que cette monnaie
la très probablement sera au niveau
asiatiques et peut-être russe sur le le
départ qu'ils n'iront pas forcément
concurrence et tout de suite
le dollar sur les autres zones et mais à
ce moment là il faut pas se tromper
la monnaie qui est le plus en danger
c'est la monnaie qui est qui est mal
montée qui est monté sur du sable c'est
à dire l'euro
d'abord et avant tout et on le voit
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qui t'avait
combien de deux personnes qui nous
annonçaient la mort du dollar oui enfin
bon en attendant le double il ou non ah
non moi jamais alors tu m'as jamais
entendu dire ça en revanche j'en ai
acheté beaucoup du dollar est ce l'effet
1 24 à 1 03 donc a priori n'est pas
encore mort le premier qui va mourir tu
as fait à 0 ou 3 1 24 à 0 3 24 si tu
veux tu le fais dans l'autre sens et moi
j'ai chanté l'euro et j'ai acheté du
j'ai acheté du d'heures donc c'est sale
mais non c'est sale c'est mais c'est
comme ça et donc est donc aujourd'hui tu
te retrouves avec un euro qui est au
tapis moi je pense que on est on est à
quelques encablures de franchir le la
parité tu vois donc on va on va
gentiment se diriger vers vers le fond
de la cave et voilà donc c'est c'est une
monnaie qui a été mal bâtisse est une
monnaie qui comme le dit charles a amené
plus de deux malheurs et de destruction
que que de deux points positifs 1 je te
rappelle quand même que quand on a mis
en place l'euro honte à annoncer quoi un
plus de chômage une croissance
extraordinaire
r ex star du x survolant tu vois là sauf
que sauf qui a rien de tout ça
malheureusement un plus de pauvreté
favor la vie était belle c'était c'était
la petite maison dans la prairie avec 7
euros sauf que quand tu regardes quand
même les quelques graphiques qui se
baladent de production industrielle de
chômage donc ça tu aperçois que c'est
pas vraiment ça colle pas avec le
l'image qu'on nous avait quand on nous
avait donné donc
oui je pense qu'il y à une perte de 2
une perte de d'hégémonie des états unis
qui peut mal se finir parce qu'ils sont
foutus de déclencher des guerres un
petit peu partout pour essayer de garder
leur oeil leur leur mainmise sur sur le
monde et
mais qu' ils sont en perte de vitesse et
que les chinois enfin ces zones là que
chine russie etc sont en train de de
monter et ils gardent eux leurs modèles
en plus c'est à dire que le bien au delà
de l'aspect purement économique et de
l'aspect purement financier
poutine s'est vraiment lentilles
lentilles by dell lentilles macron c'est
à dire le hoki sauce à lui parle pas
beaucoup à poutine
et toute cette dérive qu'on a qu'on a en
occident lui parle pas et liberté de la
presse la liberté de la presse allait
elle et elle est là en france je sais
pas moi je n'ai pas vu un mais peut-être
qu'elle est
non question a dûment un commentaire de
la communauté qui n'a rien à faire dans
la section question uniquement mais je
vais le lire quand même le gps internet
le nucléaire l'infrastructure routière
l'insuline l'informatique a été
développé par des fonds d'état est
accaparée par le privé question pour
charles s s philosophique que
d'accumuler des richesses jusqu'à en
faire vivre dix générations à rien
[__]
je connais pas d'exemple de dix
générations rien [__] et je connais
j'ai connu de l'état de grandes fortunes
historique y en a pour ainsi dire aucune
qui dure plus de trois générations
entre générations c'est foutu il ya le
grand père qu'il fait le père qui se
donne un mal de chien pour le garder et
le petit-fils qui fait les merdes est le
petit-fils qui fait n'importe quoi à une
famille française comme ça non valable
donc un aplat si on fait ça donc j'ai vu
son histoire de digérer kitty pour but
de les dix générations ça tient pas la
route et allégorique derrière un nom
mais encore une fois
c'est une question
complètement philosophique c'est le
droit de propriété
est ce que c'est un absolu
est-ce que ce qui est à moi est à moi ou
est-ce que c'est simplement un droit de
jouissance que m'accorde elle étend sur
ce que j'ai fait moi-même
ce que disait le lock qui est à
l'origine de libéralisme c'est que
l'état
c'est celui à qui on donne le monopole
de la violence légitime c'est-à-dire
qu'il peut me mettre en prison et cm1 et
que la très grande difficulté dès que
j'ai donné ce pouvoir à une série
d'hommes parce qu'il n'y a pas d'état ya
que des hommes dans l'état john locke
john locke c'est que donc dès que vous
avez donné ce pouvoir à l'état comment
je fais pour contrôler l'espèce de
monstre assassin que j'ai créée parce
que tous les crimes du 19e tous les
crimes du 20e et tous les crimes de ce
début de 21e c'est toujours des états
des crimes massifs les gens qui meurent
par millions par dizaines de millions
c'est toujours des états donc le
criminel dans l'histoire c'est comment
je contrôle ce monstre jour du business
qui pousse à la guerre derrière
c'est pas du business is business c'est
ce que j'ai croisé simplement un
mouvement que parce qu'ils avaient ils
nous empêcher d'aller à jérusalem qu'il
faut pas raconter des conneries je suis
né à alep d'un cancer
c'était chez le business tranquille ou
non non c'était pas ça c'est qu'il y
avait il y avait eu à nouveau visite
chez moi qui avais pas le pouvoir et qui
empêchaient les chrétiens d'aller on
peut les régions jérusalem donc ça
s'appelait la guerre sainte donc nous on
nous ont fait une guerre sainte contre
nous d'ailleurs ça passait et du coup
nous on a fait des croisades donc ce qui
était à l'origine ce qui nous empêcher
d'aller aux moyens ne rien faire ne
pourrait perdre n'a jamais pas que
c'était la guerre sainte qui venait
d'arabie c'est pas nous qui avons
inventé la notion c'est eux faut pas
déconner quand même hein c'est comme
l'esclavagé bon arrêtons ces arrêtons
ces trucs parce que la guerre
m'intéresse mais est ce que j'essaie de
dire simplement c'est le rôle rôle
l'état sait comment je contrôle l'état
est-ce qu'ils avaient trouvé la clé le
contrôle par les impôts par la
séparation des pouvoirs
et par le droit de propriété aujourd'hui
ledroit propriété comme l'animeront dit
ici n'existe plus en france les impôts
on les a tourné puisque on emprunte et
que sont les arrière petits enfants qui
paieront l'argent donc il ya des gens
qui vont payer des impôts pour des trucs
qui sont livrés aujourd'hui et qui n'ont
pas voté ce qui est un vrai scandale
est donc tout ce qu'on avait fait on a
plus aucun contrôle sur l'état on a une
machine folle
qui est menaces qui sont nos états tirs
dont le contrôle a été pris par une
série de gars qui sont à la limite du
grand banditisme avec les sociétés
moment et c est comment les contrôles
des citoyens n'y arrive plus c'est ça
notre c'est ça le truc quand on souffre
aujourd'hui c'est pas la gauche et la
droite c'est comment c'est ce qui
contrôle l'état et ceux qui contrôlent
pas l'état aujourd'hui les types de
davos ils sont pas ils ont donc un
problème de me2 de philosophie il
contrôle l'état et donc ils contrôlent
leurs enfants à comprendre pour pouvoir
qui a plus de contre-pouvoirs être
pouvoir taper la presse le conseil
constitutionnel le conseil de sécurité a
extrait assez pendant six à dix et à la
main de 2,2 du président
tu n'as plus tu n'as plus aucun contre
pouvoir donc si tu n'as plus aucun
contre-pouvoir tt régime libéral et on
la savait pas en régime démocratique
tu es même plus en régime démocratique
on arrive à la fin de notre interview je
vais vous demander trois bouquins vos
bouquins un conseiller notre communauté
on va commencer par charles
alors si vous voulez comprendre un peu
ce qui se passe dans le monde vous
pouvez commencez par lire
du pouvoir de bertrand de jouvenel qui
est une analyse de la façon dont
certains bouquins
c'est une façon de le justement cette
espèce de croissance continuelle et
sournoise de l'état pour enlever la
liberté des gens à quel point c'est une
espèce de bons du pouvoir de boeuf
journal sans doute un des plus grands
bouquets jamais été écrit sur le
sciences politiques le deuxième si vous
pouvez prendre
l'histoire d'un al-taybi
qui est un très bon bouquin c'est un
historien des années 30-40 en angleterre
qui a fait un très gros travail sur le
le passage des civilisations religions
c'est comment les simili les religions
font le lien entre les civilisations et
les suivis à cette assistance un bouquin
très intéressant et qui vous expliquent
bien le rôle des élites temps là dans le
développement des sociétés
c'est un très bon ok il mêlait beaucoup
d'inflation bon
il troisième bouquin je crois que c'est
un bouquin de rené girard qui s'appelle
j'ai vu ça tombait comme l'éclair c'est
une espèce de réflexion sur la notion de
bouc émissaire sur la notion de et qui
était très intéressante parce que ça
comprend ça vous êtes bien comprendre
les phénomènes de politique donc je
crois que ces trois bouquins cdc des
livres que vous pouvez lire parce que
c'est pas facile à lire à céder il faut
s'accrocher mais c'est des bouquins très
profond alors justin commenté un jeune
homme qui était philosophe anglais pays
dans lequel la propriété foncière
n'existe pas puisque les terrains
appartiennent à la couronne comment ces
principes peuvent-elles et mis en
exergue
bol approprié de n'existe pas vous avez
parfaitement par exemple à londres vous
avez des freerolls vous avez des livres
sur nos ventes nos questions non mais
vous assez le lie son amant j'avais une
maison qui était offrit à la longue
c'est à dire que je peux céder la terre
en dessous donc vous avez vous avez des
tas d'endroits où c'est hélas la terre
mais par contre ne financer que ce soit
de la grande-bretagne à partie à la
reine d'angleterre quelque part et donc
la guerre ne s'y attendait ils ont fait
puis ils ont fait un forage ou je sais
pas quoi garder ils ont trouvé du gaz
est en train de perdre
à games et à guernesey ils ont trouvé
quelque chose et du coup ça passe a
enrichi la couronne donc ça mais ça
c'est pas grave quand j'étais à hong
kong
le hang et terol surplus budgétaires
tout le temps
se demande bien pourquoi de maintenance
était pas difficile
d'imaginer la vie à maintenant mais on
s'était pas ça c'est que simplement
l'administration marché très bien et que
ils n'avaient pas idée à la con sur ce
qu'il fallait faire du pognon des gens
et même de remplir ma feuille d'impôts
cette vie c'est celle d'hier cousin la
chaise baissier c'était là c'était la
banque qui a permis la piège de la chine
par la grande bretagne dans les années
1880 c'était la guerre de l'opium mais
ça c'est autre chose
c'était pas une très bonne banque permet
donc vous avez vous avez j'avais combien
vous avez gagné cette année envoyé 17 %
merci beaucoup c'était ça mon mon truc
c'était génial
mais ce qu'ils avaient très intéressant
à hong kong c'est que le sous-sol
appartenait au gouvernement
donc vous vous rendiez un terrain
et puis
99 ans après ce retrait sera venaient
ils étaient revendus à nouveau donc
comme hong kong s'était développée sur
100 ans il y avait toujours un centième
à pas frais de nouveaux terrains qui
arrivait à échéance et on les
revendaient à 10 ou 15 ou la fois le
prix est comme ça ça allait directement
dans les caisses du et j'ai toujours
pensé que c'était une bonne idée par
exemple pour la france si on avait ainsi
décrite à posséder le terrain ça aurait
été génial parce qu'elles sont là on
n'aurait plus besoin de payer l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est simplement les gars
qui voudraient avoir quelque chose pour
son temps il achèterait et donc il y
avait une différence entre la rente
parce que le thé datsuns et mark twain
la terre c'est bien mais c'est un bon
achat parce que on n'en fait plus donc
vous avez la terre à paris elle est
limitée un don qu'il vous avez par
exemple en france un enrichissement sans
cause qui s'est produit depuis soixante
dix ans sur les appartements à paris qui
est invraisemblable qui fait la fortune
de la bourgeoisie donc ce serait pas
plus mal si bas une partie de cet
enrichissement retomber tous les cent
ans dans l'escarcelle de l'état ça
éviterait d'avoir à payer parce que ça
ils ont eu aucune raison les bobos
bourgeois parisiens de s'enrichir ils
ont fait aucun travail pour ça c'est
vraiment un enrichissement sans cause
vous parlez de l'héritage mais c'est
bien pire moi j'avais un copain qui
disait j'ai épousé une fille qui a fait
sciences po elle travaille très bien
gagne bien sa vie j'aurai beaucoup mieux
fait dépouiller une fille avait un
appartement à paris ça aurait été
bienvenu
fait pas normal
olivier trois livres coûtent y en a un
surtout qui m'a frappé mais je je je
cherche depuis cinq minutes le nom qui a
été écrit par un
ambassadeur américain dans les années
1800 quelques et qui
sur le
l'effondrement des assignats en france
et
donc tu vois les
voiles et les discours des différents
députés qui
qui parlait justement de cette de cette
planche à billets de cette de cet
effondrement après et c'est assez
curieux parce que tu crois moi
tu n'aurais pas les dates tu n'aurais
pas les noms tu entends les discours de
maintenant c'est mot pour mot les
discours à l'assemblée les les propos de
bruno le maire s'est c'est étonnant mais
vraiment étonnant donc c'est un c'est un
livre il faut que je joue il faut juste
que je retrouve son son nom c'est un
livre
je te dis il faut faire l'exercice faut
s'amuser faut faut supprimer les noms
faut supprimer les dates et tu as la
répétition de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui comme quoi
finalement c'était quand même pas très
compliqué
depuis déjà un bon moment de se dire que
s'ils ont refusé sans cesse les mêmes
choses il est assez probable qu'on
arrive au même résultat est
malheureusement c'était attendu donc
n'avait pas besoin
d'être
très
très intelligent pour comprendre ça
malheureusement nos soi disant élites ne
l'ont pas compris et voilà ça c'est un
petit bouquin que j'ai j'ai lu il ya un
petit moment déjà mais
c'est pas très très long c'est assez
c'est assez
amusant parce que bien écrit il faut
juste que je retrouve le nom
outre les deux autres pour l'instant
j'ai pas parce que ça fait ça fait une
bonne année que j'ai pas eu le temps de
lire tu vois une bonne année que
j'arrête pas donc
parce que justement il ya beaucoup de
gens qui commencent à s'apercevoir qu'il
ya un petit souci est donc ça fait ça
fait un an que je travaille comme un fou
et que j'ai pas le temps dira alors un
conseil pour les jeunes générations ce
sera la prochaine question j'en profite
pour dire que tous ou sur notre forum
qui n'ont pas posé des questions la
partie questions uniquement vont se
retrouver dehors ce soir parce qu' on va
faire un peu le ménage et donc charles
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelque chose d'impérissables qui va
rester sur le net oui c'est pas très
difficile c'est en aucun cas vous ne
restez dans un endroit où vous emmerder
quelle que soit l'explication quel que
soit votre situation n'importe quoi vous
ne devez en aucun cas accepter l'ennui
travailler c'est une bénédiction si ce
que vous si vous faites ce que vous
aimez et à ce moment là vous réussirez
donc si on vous a collée dans un endroit
où vous emmerder vous vous battez vous
dit merci beaucoup mais il faut pas
rester un endroit
et si vous y restez pas ce que vous
pensez que vous aurez une retraite et je
peux vous annoncer une nouvelle c'est
que vous aurez pas d'autres attaques
donc ce n'est pas la peine que vous y
restent y est de toute façon vous leviez
ayez l'esprit critique
ne prenez pas pour argent comptant tout
ce qu'on vous raconte et l'esprit
critique
sur sur tout et sur tout ce qu'on vous
dit et surtout
sur ce que les plus menteurs vous dis
c'est à dire les hommes politiques avant
de couper je voudrais bien à ricains qui
va se faire piquer ce soir parce qu'il
n'a pas posé une question mais qui nous
a fait encore un commentaire bonsoir en
tout cas on a bien compris que le privé
a le monopole de la vertu de l'honnêteté
et de l'intelligence non c'est pas du
tout sur le privé a le monopole de
l'échec
c'est à dire si vous êtes mauvais dans
le privé ou si vous avez pris des
mauvaises décisions mauvais mois à
sauter vous perdez vous sautez vous
disparaissez le privé c'est une école de
darwinisme tandis que si vous êtes dans
le secteur public vous pouvez rester
pendant des années à faire des trucs qui
servent à rien et c'est honteux donc je
veux dire par là c'est que il n'ya pas
de réussite s'il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'échec est ce que vous
trouvez que je vous ai pas porter la
contradiction ce soir au bruno pas du
tout je vous ai pas pensé de
contradictions et tout souvent un
changement sous jules libéral les gens
doivent penser ce qu'ils veulent
d'accord c'est à dire mais je leur
demande de ne pas penser comme moi j'ai
créé une boîte qui s'appelle guerre call
dans lequel on a 1000 clients dans le
monde qui sont toutes les grandes
sociétés de gestion et tous les gars qui
sont là je leur ai dit enfin les gains
pas nos clients les gars qui travaillent
on a une soixantaine maintenant 70
pendant mes années et bien je le redis
en aucun cas il n'y a pas d'esprit
maison ici il n'y a pas de décision
maison vous avez le droit de dire que le
chairman moi dit des conneries
parce que c'est comme ça que vous vous
bâtirez
est contre moi écrit aux yeux des
clients mais donc je ne demande pas ce
que les gens soient d'accord avec moi je
leur exposé mes idées
s'ils sont contents très bien mais ça ne
veut pas dire que je prétends que j'ai
la vérité la vérité titin thénia bhl
mais on peut se rapprocher en discutant
entre gens de bonne compagnie mais je ne
veux pas qu'on m'empêche de dire ma
vérité
luigi sur ta remarque la deux
river qui est paraître toutes les vertus
en fait le problème je suis d'accord
c'est que le privé est sanctionné
normalement
mais depuis monsieur macron il l'est
plus c'est ce qu'on appelle le
capitalisme de connivence
donc la prison voilà est donc en fait on
a empêché la destruction créatrice on a
empêché les coins les les boîtes son be2
tomber on les a foulé on l'a on les a
empêché de tomber et donc on a empêché
le système capitaliste qui est tu fais
une connerie tu la payes voilà donc
qu'on n'est pas du tout dans un système
capitaliste on n'est pas du tout dans un
système libéral si on était dans un
système libéral y aurait beau il y
aurait beaucoup plus de chômage aurait
beaucoup plu entreprises par terre parce
que là on a refusé justement le système
mono voilà donc l'état intervient
partout aujourd'hui on est à un dernier
recours seulement parlera peut-être que
des boules ou comme en allemagne à 300
euros pays où lens pire quand je dors
d'allemagne de gt à munich j'ai été à
francfort j'étais à düsseldorf était
partout en allemagne c'est un partout
salanon j'entends bien mais il ya
peut-être des gars qui touche 300 mais
sans doute parce qu'il ya le système de
l'impôt négatif qu'ils ont mis en
allemagne ce n'est pas complètement
idiot mais les gens ont l'air assez
prospère ils ont pas ils ont pas je vois
assez peu de deux géants très malheureux
de qui meurent de faim quand je vais à
la balle à palop à la porte sur deux
niveaux d'abord que de quoi je vois des
gens qui ont l'air quand même un peu
plus je vois jamais genre de truc en
allemagne où donc encore une fois si
vous voulez on peu pas à partir du
moment où vous parlez d'un pays à niveau
de vie quasiment le plus élevé au monde
avec les suisses il ya certainement des
gars qui ne réussissent pas s'en sortir
qui sont dans des trois rats où j'en
sais rien mais c'est pas c'est pas la
règle c'est pas la norme la plupart des
gens vivent confortablement élèves leurs
familles comme il faut et se portent pas
plus mal que ça donc c'est pas encore
une fois vous pouvez pas prendre un cas
du gars qui est complètement drogué ou
je sais pas quoi qui réussit pas
travailler et vous dit regardez ce
soleil il est très malheureux en
allemagne et même s'ils font que deux ou
trois pourcent de la population c'est
trop
mais il ya 97 pour tournon population
qui vit très bien merci c'est c'est pas
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est les 97 pour
ça les deux pour cent y aider à gagner
sur de charité pour sa question je vous
connais déjà la réponse et après vous
coupent renflouer les banques ces
capitalistes pour interrogation non non
il faut ça mais je ne suis rien contre a
renfloué les banques parce que les
banques c'est en inde un truc très
curieux j'ai beaucoup écrit là-dessus
j'ai rien contre renflouer les banques
mais à ce moment là il faut mettre à
zéro les actionnaires
messieurs merci
[Musique]